I heard you guys ribbon last time
citizens of the reject Nation if we are
live you know what to do
leave a like leave a like leave a like
that's what you got to do to let us know
you we are live here right now like for
live like live like for the live leave a
like for live it's been a while since
John and I were doing this if I'm gonna
get this out of the way right now
I need to take a crap
I don't know I'll hold the stream down
while you go answer the call
Ghostbusters 2016. um oh hold on uh yeah
I wanted to uh mention that people might
be going where's koi where's koi genre
well koi I would like him to take over
this segment one day for just MCU and
DCU that's that that's the goal
um however it's just funny because it's
the weekend where we're getting a secret
Invasion trailer and the next day we're
getting a spider-verse trailer and then
we're getting a Blue Beetle trailer that
same day we're getting three comic book
movie trailers and there's a bunch of
movie news
and Coy's out of town
it's like the prime weekend and he's
just away doing panels yeah yeah it's
he's a way doing panels and make it come
he's hosting some major major panels
some Mega panels so yeah man it's a
maker con panels maybe he's bumping into
3C films over there uh so yeah he's not
here with us today and it's so John you
got to be the new you got to be coy you
got to have the knowledge okay rejection
okay rejected
my veins are popping out of my forehead
let's drink like 10g fuels and I just
did like four you know upper body
workouts before coming here on rated
talk Comics
um so yeah all right we got a good
amount of people in the chat uh we got
267 viewers right now yeah Maria and
Hammond gave me this thing but we got a
few things to talk about that we know we
want to talk about but as per usual you
know we will eventually get to just
opening up the chat q a because there's
always so much more that we didn't even
consider talking about it's going to be
guided by you folks in the chat the
reject Nation out there it is one of our
best ways to connect with the community
engaged engaged with your audience right
is how you do this so quick shout outs
to Greg Elijah Ashley Ann and I see dude
we do have a super chat here from povin
Meyer
um I want to say also really quick thank
you to everyone who super chatted us
last live stream and also contribute to
our stream Labs we got so much last time
it kept us live for much longer than we
had planned to and we know what we love
when a situation like that occurs so
thank you guys so much your support
means a lot John you decide today since
you are the new koi good
um what is the first thing that we
should discuss I'm gonna while I
rearrange this I mean should we take
this first Super Chat as it is part of
the the headline of news that has been
compiled for this very live stream I
feel like it's a perfect kickoff all
right sure let's read that first Super
Chat head up povin Meyer povin Meyer
thanks to povin Meyer yes what does he
say John while I rearrange life here
povin Meyer says Doug Jones for clay
phase but it's not like the comics
elaborate disguises instead of the more
sci-fi a version that would be an intro
I mean Doug Jones for any kind of
creature or or just like heavy
prosthetic or effects Laden character is
always like a a great choice I'm curious
about the idea I don't know see that's
the thing is I feel like you have to
have some kind of body horror-ish
element or some kind of like physical
John we gotta start we gotta rewind all
right let's explain what's going on you
know just start talking you're the
structure what kind of koi are you I am
the color commentary if you are the main
commentator that's why you throw to
yourself first uh okay so Batman 2
there's been heavy uh speculation rumors
and whatnot that Clayface will be a
prominent figure in the upcoming sequel
to Matt Reeves is the Batman and thus
povin Meyer is now speculating as to who
could play said Clayface in this movie
through that son and uh yeah I think
Doug Jones again as I said it a moment
ago would be a terrific choice I am
curious as to what the chat would think
of a uh yeah a disguise Master rather
than a person who's you know whole face
and and body or you know like malleable
like clay yeah I feel like there is
something that you could do in the
tradition of various film Noir and I
think Sin City has already capitalized
this on the sort of like you know I
changed my face to start a new life but
even more like I feel like there's still
some room for Fantasy in Matt Reeves
world even though it is much more real
and grounded so I I feel like they could
come up with something gross and
unsettling for Clayface but I feel like
costuming like just disguises might be a
little too simplified almost yeah yeah
so Clayface did you go through about I
was making some notes Here I was half
paying attention I want to go back and
make like basic chapters for this live
stream for the playback so leave a like
that helps with the playback uh did you
go over like a little bit of who clay
faces No No I want you you know that you
have a much more comprehensive I mean
the basic version of Clayface well
there's two versions one I didn't
actually know about until yesterday
which was the original version of clay
phase I didn't I thought it was always
what I grew up with via Comics via
Batman the Animated Series via the
Arkham games I I always thought it was
actor and it was a play on the fact that
uh he the scientific [__] happens and
then Clayface can molt so it was and but
in the original version of of Clayface
like the very OG version he was an actor
who did not get recap who did not get to
reprise a role for a remake that was
being made of his film and so he became
clay face the villain which was just
like a bad guy just a normal bad guy now
there's this like Metamorphosis quality
to him where he can literally full on
imitate people and I think you know
it would be interesting to get two clay
faces because we have the rumor that
Mike Flanagan and Mike Flanagan didn't
exactly debunk this it seemed that he
was kind of putting it out there Mike
Flanagan who made Haunting of Hill House
uh hunting a blind Manor and uh midnight
mass have you seen that yet you son of a
[__]
one of my favorite writer directors
working today and supposedly he pitched
like a Clayface movie
and I think he could do that tragic
Fantastical quality very well then you
could also see Clayface working within
the main chapter one of Gods and
Monsters where it is like something in
the Batman brave in the Bold universe
that does go that far
it doesn't excite me at the prospect of
not ha of Clayface just being like a
regular Thief it doesn't excite me as as
being just a regular bad guy or a mess
like I liked what they did with Riddler
but it still felt enough like Riddler
with the riddling happening in the film
yeah with Clayface I think it's just
such a trademark quality of him now that
I don't know you might as well just make
him like chameleon which is a Spider-Man
villain
chameleon instead of just getting a
chance to be clay face you know I feel
like you could probably blend the two
takes the two Origins for the character
together in some sense you know you can
make you know some kind of spiraling out
from you know the actor into something
greater and something more crime
oriented yeah oh my God I would love
Chris Pratt play Clayface that's the guy
he is like a real life clay face he's
just always morphing and changing and
coming up with characters that you would
never recognize him in yes yes Chris
Pratt over there I want to make sure we
get to our titles um but yeah I imagine
there'd be multiple villains in the
Batman part two you know probably
penguin returning Joker somewhere in
there this is April 1st I forgot this
was April 1st which is April Fool's Day
so I I'm not gonna lie I had a panic
attack once I saw there was a bunch of
news that came out on Twitter today only
to be like yeah wait a minute this is
bull [__] and I forget that like
mainstream Outlets like Hollywood
Reporter participate yeah yeah that was
like a panic on the rider like just
checking checking stuff
everything I've been prepared for is now
is now just like completely out the
window do I have to adjust for all this
stuff oh boy yeah hey Yeti x what about
patrons what's going on buddy what about
super sexy rejects the sex thank you
guys I know we got some more Super chess
we'll get to them in just a little bit I
want to make sure that we're getting to
I like I like your picks for Clayface in
the chat who would you have playface
Kevin James is a fantastic pick Jim
Holland cast him twice actually Jim
Carrey wouldn't be a bad pick Jim Carrey
would be a great pick for he's already
Clayface I think Matt Reeves though if
he does go with him he he has a he does
an excellent job at going against what
you would normally who you normally
expect to play
um any of these characters 90 of the
time except for Zoe Kravitz and and uh
and uh and what you may call it um
what's his name my God Jeffrey Wright
Jeffrey commissioner that's right Gordon
thank you to everyone who left a like
there's a lot uh Sergeant let's talk
about this Spider-Man news because
that's the that's one of our headlines
for today oh yeah it's a Spider-Man four
plot details going off memory no notes
going on John you're gonna I'm gonna
need some uh I got you I need some
assist here I got you I'm here so the
Spiderman for plot details are uh or the
main there's been some reliable sources
like sources that have been proven that
hey they've been right kind of a lot of
the time and nothing too spoiler heavy
here
um but you know what uh setups yeah some
setups and this is all rumors none of
this is confirmed I could see it being
plausible though and you might have
already heard and I did want to touch on
this
so what's it all starts with Kingpin
funny enough yes all roads lead to
Kingpin so Kingpin as we know is going
to be returning in the Echo series after
dying and being resurrected by the
Lazarus Pit he his returning in the Echo
series and of course he's going to be in
Daredevil born again and supposedly he
will be one of the main bad guys for
Spider-Man 4. so it's supposed to be
following a certain kind of comic run
where Kingpin once elected for mayor
what he fights for is to have Vigilantes
like the street Vigilantes Daredevil
I mean Punisher you know uh the rest of
the Defenders everyone who's had a
television show basically yeah and then
Spider-Man who after the events of no
way home would just be more of a
street-level hero again a protector a
neighborhood friendly Spider-Man to
Outlaw vigilantes in New York which is
actually a a concept that I'm surprised
it hasn't been brought up in the MCU yet
we have a very street level MCU to speak
of thus far at least on the big screen I
don't feel like in in the TV shows more
so what I mean by that is the
conversation of isn't this a crime being
a vigilante isn't this a crime sure what
they're doing of course Kingpin isn't
doing this to protect the people of New
York City he has his own best interests
at heart uh it's something that is more
corrupt so the theory goes that with the
outlawing of Vigilantes he would of
course like if you've played the the
first Spider-Man PS4 game that's kind of
a good idea good way to gauge a sort of
where I'm imagining they can go with
it's just not with that many villains in
there
however it probably hires a villain or
two maybe scorpion so that way he can be
the one uh to go after and take down
Spider-Man I imagine Jay Jonah Jameson
would be folded back into the mix and be
even more prevalent who is going yes
this is illegal this is cry this is
Criminal what these heroes are doing
they're not government sanctioned that's
why we have sokovia chords in place I
think as we're you know as much as
there's been focus on what does the
Multiverse mean for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and as much hype as there's
been for like Avengers King Dynasty and
Secret Wars I'm weirdly more interested
in this because this feels more intimate
this feels darker because
it's posing a like I think that's why
the conversation surrounding Captain
America Civil War was so fascinating and
I feel like with Spider-Man and these
other Heroes like Daredevil especially
Daredevil who has like a law background
it's I think it'd just be way more
intriguing to deal with
is this actually like criminal activity
and what are they fighting for they're
also being shunned by half of the public
like you can get a little political as
much as people say like that shouldn't
be in our movies it's in the comics you
can get a little political about it and
make something that's truly pulsating
and on the run and I think even
something like Captain America New World
Order would be dealing with that set up
on a bigger scale too kind of this
reoccurring theme and conversation going
throughout Marvel phase five and six
and then you got like a Multiverse thing
going on at the same time and I think
having that for the street level is more
intriguing in my opinion but what do you
guys think John what do you think of
Kingpin yeah being this villain yeah no
I think I mean a that's very exciting
because I you know having Vincent
D'Onofrio back has been an interest an
odd Prospect because everyone's
obviously excited about his portrayal
everybody loves his take on the
character he loves playing the character
but you know we're still I think waiting
for that satisfying return and we're
also waiting on the big screen live
action to see Spider-Man take on Kingpin
who has either been a prolific
Spider-Man villain over the course of
time and I think right now is a point
where I I think the MCU could maybe
benefit from a little contrast because
we are going so big in Cosmic and
multiversal and I'm here for that stuff
I really like the Fantastical and the
strange however I think it is uh
beneficial to them to have a contrast
with the more street level stuff and to
have those kinds of conversations too
it's like they had some interesting
stuff going on especially with ever
everything that transpired leading into
Civil War and the debate about you know
Heroes that led to sokovic Accords and
all that stuff
um I think you know you can easily
imagine a world in which Jay Jonah
Jameson is like helping campaign for
Kingpin and you know and using all those
resources to throw at Spider-Man along
with you know the other physical Stakes
that he'll have to face and so yeah that
seems like something that would be I
think they said there's like a contract
issue where like Spider-Man has to
appear Spiderman Spiderman has to bring
you know an MCU buddy another prolific
character along you know it can't just
be only solely Spider-Man at the center
of the movie for some reason
um but I like the idea of that being
Kingpin because that does suggest a more
physical challenge and something that is
going to be you know uh even though
Kingpin is a fantastic character you
know he's just a man with his fists and
his Force so I think it'll be really fun
and interesting to see Spider-Man take
that on and you know he's such a
colorful character in Vincent
d'onofrio's hands that I just can't wait
to see them quit back and forth together
you know and and
you know really find that sort of
adversarial uh friction I would love
that I love where your head's at Joe
plus the opportunity to get a daredevil
team up is just too good to pass up and
if Kingpin is uh in Spider-Man's past
and you know Daredevil is going to come
into the picture and that's like the
coolest idea like that's something that
I think could unequivocally get people
hyped no matter what reservations you
have about phase four and five and six
well I was hearing um I don't know this
came out I saw this on comic book cast
um I'm just making a little chapter note
Spider-Man bought by Disney so
apparently I don't know how how much how
true this is
um because I'm seeing seeing some people
in the chat bringing some things up
about Spider-Man buying Disney but the
chat was moving a little bit quick here
um oh thank you unnamed film channel for
attending our WonderCon panel uh or that
that is that WonderCon panel was pretty
awesome
worked off two hours of sleep that day
and so it was a bit of a blur to me but
it was awesome uh but yeah so a big one
of the one of the things going around
right now is that Disney officially
bought Spider-Man for 4.1 billion
dollars
and it's in five years where they would
have all the rights so Amy Pascal right
now is helping to
oversee the the remaining phase the
remaining parts of the Spider-Man was
like Madame Webb and whatever else
they're doing
Spiderman buying Disneyland is that what
I said originally Spider-Man Spider-Man
that would be a very interesting
takeover so yeah friendly neighborhood
media conglomerate I only saw this on
comic book casts who often just reports
on the news this was not released on
April 1st it was March 31st so unless
they were really trying to get ahead of
the game time zone are they in it's 19
hours
okay I am finding it from Hardware Zone
forums here yeah from 14 hours ago which
would be that's that's late last night I
I don't know if it's true or not
um
I I feel like that would be cool though
certainly I mean I think that would give
everybody this is a doctor strange Cape
by the way yes it is not a spectacular
Cape as much as everyone says that it's
not a promotion for the hit film coming
up was it an April Fool's joke it feels
like it because I saw it posted like
March 31st
were they in Europe I don't know if they
are no I'm curious I mean like if it is
true I think people would be very
excited if it's not true good joke I
think this stream it would be way more
fun if we had more
if we had more fake news
it's actually true yeah we can leave
little polls do you think this story is
true yes or no because today's our
today's our April 1st yes it is yeah
it's we're 11 and a half hours into
April first you know and I as I don't
know when this com this combo cast thing
came out it I saw it yesterday and it
said 19 hours ago so I'm like I can't
have it April 1st yes but that would be
cool if that was the case anyway uh I
know we we've got in a few super chats I
want to make sure I just feel like the
big Outlets would would all be reporting
that what are your guys's thoughts yes
on Velma I think we should react to that
react to the film
Lady Gaga's out you guys know how to
trigger my anxiety yes this stream is
over let me just try to let me just make
sure first because I only pull this up
now if we have successfully fallen
behind
clay face Poison Ivy and scarecrow will
be a part of the Batman 2 is that true
Vengeance that would be very a very cool
Trio I mean I'm always rooting for a
scarecrow appearance and uh you know
poison ivy I feel like Matt Reeves's
take would be fascinating okay yeah so
John we we oh no we have not fallen
behind here we go we're doing good all
right okay we got a new piece of news in
this next one so here we go
um John where's that's spoil their talk
graphic here all right it's up at the
top title overlay so we we're
implementing this there's basically
something that Ben Affleck spoiled
regarding the flash a scene that
supposedly is actually cut out of the
movie now so I don't think it's that big
of a spoiler sure
um because
if everything is happening with the DC
Universe and on top of that too
everyone's saying that it's cut out of
the movie this is just how they mark it
now
but I wanted to talk about this scene
because
it when reading the quotes especially
from Ben Affleck it was the first time
you know what because this whole time my
my mindset has been Ben Affleck has just
wanted to move on and just have everyone
shut the [__] up about that like let him
be right let me and then he the way he
was talking about specifically when
going over to this scene
and the way he was being like Oh I know
I quit but man I finally figured it out
and stuff like oh it seems like he was
actually kind of
you know there was a partner was a
little bit there's a little hints of
like maybe I want to go yeah
circumstances I would love to explore
more now that I finally know how to play
the guy uh going off memory of the scene
I'm gonna put up this graphic this is
when we're gonna be done once this
graphic goes away and please help us out
in the chat if someone comes in and goes
hey what are they talking about it says
talking spoilers here what's the spoiler
talking about please let them know what
it is
um so I'm just gonna put that right
there I'm able to move this on screen
John yeah
you can move it wherever you like and
you can change the size that's right
please there you go
King spoilers yeah I'm gonna put this
right here for now yeah okay cool groovy
so what happened in case you guys
haven't heard it's really not that big
of a deal but there's a scene that
happens in The Flash movie Apparently
that is now cut out of the film where
did you read about this I did okay I
know the report all right so
Ben Affleck's Batman at one point is
rescued by Wonder Woman and she used and
part of rescuing him is using the lasso
of Truth so you know when the last truth
is wrapped around you what comes out the
truth about how you really feel under
yeah he poops he just shits everywhere
and Ben Affleck was like I now know how
to play about that he's always on the
face always happens
[Laughter]
if I don't [__] I will Channel my rage I
know how to play Batman now
forget about the pain in my intestine
yeah anyway yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah no
he he tells he spills some sort of
intimate truths about himself in this
moment to Wonder Woman and through that
I guess it helped Ben Affleck to sort of
Greater understand the depth of Bruce
Wayne and how to play him yeah which
would have been a fascinating scene to
see because especially with Ben
Affleck's Batman who is the furthest
thing from open and vulnerable like you
already kind of associate that with
Batman as a as a gentleman who has a
hard time opening up what we've seen
like with Christian Bales and and uh
Val kilmers at least you know get a
little bit of a soft they would have
moments where they get soft and
vulnerable
and with Ben Affleck's you don't get
that and I I think it would have been an
interesting thing to actually have that
scene unfold so yeah he does spoil that
oh you would have gotten this really
heartfelts and that Wonder Woman makes
it makes a solid appearance in that film
and it seems like they they cut that
whole thing out and I would be curious
to know to have that scene at least
revealed one day because
I imagine that was one of his more
emotional scenes that he's ever had to
have filmed you know it feels like one
of those things that could easily be
like a heart swell of like relief like
oh cool oh surprise Wonder Woman's here
but also yeah like a surprisingly
poignant moment between two characters
that do know each other and have history
you know on screen for a lot of the dce
would have helped narratively Drive the
plot forward of whatever's going on with
helping to transition the Batman out
sure like that kind of probably could
have aided in being a goodbye scene for
him yeah literally a moment of
vulnerability before we yeah say goodbye
you know peek into his soul would be a
really nice sort of way to cap that off
however you know not to say that there
was not another scene they do have and
plan to keep in the movie that could
serve that purpose as well uh I don't
know I like I yeah I'm I'm sad to hear
if it's not in the movie because it
seems like a cool idea and you know you
could easily then add it to the classic
list of scenes where people are
interacting with the lasso like Aquaman
and Justice League and now this so uh
you know we're being robbed we're being
robbed right robbed but yeah I don't
know I I would love to see the scene in
some form I don't know how do you guys
feel about the scene getting cut out
does it bother you are you pissed this
video is sponsored by athletic greens
athletic greens
as we talk about [__] several times
on this stream today keep yourself
regular yourself shooting some more with
athletic greens don't [__] out junk food
[__] has some good vitamins and minerals
all right move past that thing but
thanks for asking cool cash G hey DC
loves Henry you goddamn right they do
Henry Cavill for Wonder Woman John
what's going on here what's with this
button I don't know
gotta get rid of this button I don't
know uh all right that's fine all right
Alvin Lane thank you so much for the
Super Chat my friend from patreon Ellen
Ling what's up uh we just gave you a big
old group shout out hey Greg and John hi
I know we were getting a secret Invasion
trailer but we're also getting
spider-verse and Blue Beetle I don't
know exciting look out yeah the scoopers
been scooping and it looks like it's
happening uh secret Invasion trailer
manana
spider-verse I think it's crazy they
were getting all three it's just like
and is there something going on if it
feels like there should be a consistency
event like E3 just got canceled so it
can't be that because there's also
supposed to be the trailer
um that I'm hearing rumors about for the
Robert Rodriguez directed Ben Affleck
movie
and we're Wonder Woman Wonder Woman we
just spoiled it
without the spoiler reporting on her and
then we also are getting rumors that and
it looks likely as well that the new
Hunger Games trailers coming out this
week oh good everyone's excited for the
new Hunger Games somehow I gotta squeeze
in a Creed Three movie reaction as well
it's gonna be good pull an all-nighter
for the Mandalorian so it suddenly
turned into a very daunting week very
busy week which is a good problem to
have it's just I don't understand
sometimes with these trailer releases I
don't get it where they you'll you'll
get nothing
for so long especially now and then then
there'll be a weekend where they're like
hey fire everything yeah every Studio
goes just release it off yeah yeah that
was the time that's what they want maybe
that's it let's have overlap with each
other let's do Mass scarcity and then
just a whole batch release all at once
yeah it's it's strange because two they
don't release these things as far out in
advance as it seems like they used to it
seems like nowadays like three months
out is kind of The Sweet Spot and we are
heading right into summertime like
spring just started you know 10-ish days
ago or you know 11 days ago and uh yeah
it's like we're heading toward the
beginning of what will be summer season
so it makes sense to start getting
trailers but also it is like what is it
about this weekend what is it about
April Fool's weekend that is so special
um but yeah very excited to see what all
of them look like especially a new
Robert Rodriguez joint I know and I've
heard good things it played at uh what's
that called s m
sxsida says sex in the chat because yeah
that that one always sounds like sex to
me yeah um yeah and apparently they they
screen an early cutter Rodriguez's movie
there but it's still got amazing
feedback and I was so happy to hear that
for Robert Rodriguez I know I'm always
rooting
Jim Carrey's old Clayface so many people
could play clayfic get Brian Cox in my
face I think he would be a good clay
face in Matt Reeves Universe Shadow
realm BG thank you so much for the Super
Chat here hey hey greetings from
Bulgaria do you think secret Invasion
going to deliver bigger than we think
keep doing the good content
I think the new conversation we need to
have surrounding the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is
I'll be patient and wait yes instead of
this is going to be a game changer I
feel like it'll be a good thing uh I'm
planning on reading see I could I could
I looked at how long the Run was for
seeking Invasion I feel like I can read
it uh pretty fast I'm planning on
reading it closer to one secret Invasion
debuts even though I feel like it's
probably gonna be nothing like I think
in the comic
um because I'm aware of what happens in
the comic but I think that with secret
Invasion it is essentially picking up
from events from Captain Marvel more
than anything else
um that'll be a lot more honed in and
focused on characters like Talos and
Nick Fury and what they're dealing with
and you kind of get I don't mean Captain
America
rephrase not Civil War doesn't make a
cold war Vibe about it yeah yeah yeah
yeah you get this sort of feels like the
Civil War you know it's like the
American like Ulysses S Grant yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah emancipating all of the
Scrolls yeah uh no yeah I think this
could be a certain opportunity at least
to return to to return to a tone not
exactly like the Winter Soldier but
something that has that political
thriller Vibe and yes something that
Harkens more toward Cold War paranoia
type movies especially like that's a
really good uh uh Touchstone yeah
because it's like who is hiding Among Us
who is you know the concealed enemy you
know dressed as our friend and whatever
else and what sort of interesting
conversations can you have based on that
like I think it is a good opportunity
for them to do something rich uh and I
hope that they take it uh yeah I'm sort
of same thing I I'm I'm waiting to see
how everything pans out and I'm trying
not to let my excitement Carry Me Away
ahead of myself for these different
things because the shows have shown uh
over I think average at least there are
certain shows that really kind of nail
it across the board but a lot of them
have these really great elements and
then have these particular shortcomings
that aren't too hard to spot and so I'm
hoping that they're just taking notes on
all this I think it's good that they are
taking their time granted this has been
you know uh it's part of the wave of
like we're gonna do tons and tons of
content
um but I I hope that this can kind of
set a new sort of stage for what's to
come tonally well it sounds like it
could also be surprisingly personal I
think so too yeah yeah and I mean I
really liked the Scrolls and their sort
of storyline in Captain Marvel and the
relationship with uh Talos and Nick Fury
so like I'm excited to see that stuff
extrapolated on
you know and and two just the fun of you
know peep shapeshifters and copycats we
must move on I'm secretly doing this I
can I what is that what are you doing
where's the show where's the words I was
just responding to now I don't know what
I was talking about Dakota Jones we got
some from Dakota Jones our good friend
one virus effects over here let's
interrupt this this is not confirmed
tasm three I will not fall you gotta do
better everyone Ah that's a that's an
April Fool right I want to see who in
the chat can contribute and April Fool's
headline to me and actually yeah yeah
like what is convincing but don't worry
that's true that would be yeah I would
have stopped this stream right now John
you were reading Dakota Jones yeah no
there's no news report Dakota Jones Will
Bill Skarsgard playing Pennywise uh with
Bill Skarsgard now the crow and
Nosferatu what other iconic role Cosmic
or horror could you you see him tackle
next I don't want him to play a villain
next I want him to play like actually
make him Jason Todd I want him to do
that I feel like he'd be a fantastic
Clayface sure great idea actually yeah
yeah yeah yeah because no matter which
version the Mike Flanagan more artistic
fan of the Opera Vibe Gothic horror
version the the Batman Matt Reeves
version or even the more fun side of the
DCU of James Gunn I think well that's
the thing yeah as you could uh Clayface
is a fun opportunity because there are
so many takes and so many Origins and
and many characters who have worn that
mantle and you could really crash a lot
of those things together yeah even like
so many of them don't necessarily
preclude the others so you could make
them all part of this weird sort of
amorphous history and yeah Bill
Skarsgard honestly that's a good call
man it would be I think him as Clayface
would be good honestly well then cast
them uh people have been asking about a
Dun Dungeons and Dragons in the chat and
uh I personally am waiting for it to
come to VOD it's up to John if he wants
to wait or not absolutely wait it sounds
like a blast and I would I'm not asking
you to wait I'm saying you have the
choice it would be a joy to react to you
so unless you're giving me a thinly
veiled hint that you don't I don't want
you near me
I'm not picking up I'm more than happy
to enjoy it with you here in the lovely
and Posh real reject Studio my uncle
thank you for this thingy I don't know
the Creed was my one for the year
yeah I was like I'll see this no I
always have to I will never ask anyone
else to wait unless it's like please
John Wayne yes cocaine bear was like hey
did you see this in theaters now all
right let's react to it yeah
um okay I'll be there for Evil Dead
don't worry
um Colby Stephens uh Transformers
official trailer will drop this week
geez Jesus Christo the part that
stresses me about this even though I
know people don't require us to be
experts is I really do my best to to
research a bunch beforehand and and it
bums me out because my brain can only
handle so much because I don't just have
a memory game I got it because it's like
it's always diverted between like oh my
personal the other things I'm working on
and then editing and whatever and my my
Noggin can like to give you an example I
watched all of Attack on Titan and then
part three comes out I'm like ah [__] I
need a I need a refresher and then I
decided I'm just going to read the Manga
because it's pretty accurate to the show
and I'm reading it and I'm almost done
with where I need to catch up to and I'm
like I forgot so much of what happened I
didn't remember the most important
history impact stories leading in so my
brain just misses stuff all the like
because and and it sucks because I do I
do commit a lot of time in a research
side or to either watch especially I'll
read a lot of the actual Source material
or I'll take the time to like watch the
Star Wars animated shows and then I'll
still miss stuff and it bums me up
that's bum me up I want to see a map so
Transformers of like oh my God I don't
remember so much about it the Beast Wars
now yeah I don't know anyone who's a
Transformers expert
you could you could hire John Bailey I
could hire John Bailey actually it's not
bad call
yeah he's the Transformer Joshua J
Gonzalez thank you for joining in and
and participating and contributing I
just noticed that you guys aren't
sitting on your actual chairs we are
actually however they've been rearranged
placed in different spots true yeah I'm
usually in the spider chair when I'm
with the G train but uh we're on the
different sides today uh I want to talk
about Michael Mando super quick for just
one minute yes
um because Michael Mando if you guys
don't know he was in Better Call Saul as
nacho but also he was scorpion in the
Spider-Man Homecoming movie and I like
that really didn't do much for me for
him and homecoming I was like huh sucks
with that actor to not be coming back
but after seeing him as nacho and Better
Call Saul
bit would be a complete oh man uh you
are missing out on a great opportunity
because he is phenomenal in that series
phenomenal
and I would hope that if any of these
rumors for the next Spider-Man movie are
true I mean you got to bring scorpion
into the equation like we haven't gotten
scorpion yet you got to bring scorpion
into the equation and if you don't bring
Michael Mando back you are doing
yourself a disservice Sony and Marvel
well yeah I mean he and uh Adrian tombs
are in prison together so yeah or they
were until Adrian tombs got sprung so
true gotta come back in some way shape
or form
uh let's see here Cruz Rivera thank you
for the moment of silence
and uh yeah and uh you know Velma is
definitely coming reactions in the
series oh yeah yeah we're gonna
prioritize Velma I want to watch a show
to hate it all all week rage watch we
won't we won't win with Velma hello to
Venezuela it's nice to have you in the
chat uh what do you think of Tyler's
returning Captain America four I'm sure
it'll be a great Cameo yeah I do it I
love everybody I feel like it's going to
be as special as people think it's more
like yeah it's just still remember she
still counts yeah I know just still
count this movie is still technically
Canon even though the universal stuff is
hinky yeah no I mean I've seen all those
reports of people going like well they
can't make a Hulk movie called The Hulk
so they're just gonna make Captain
America The Hulk yeah and I'm like I
don't think that's gonna happen even if
there are red hulks and other characters
relevant to the Hulk even if the Hulk
himself is a big character I think it
would be a pretty disrespectful to
Anthony mackie's first feature is
Captain America to make it a Hulk movie
instead you know I need a I need a I
need a oh my god oh we did it always
afraid you've got a loser so money baby
you're better than me at this I mean I I
did see Aaron but briefly saw it in this
quick scheme but I would love for
Daredevil to appear in the next
Spider-Man movie I think if there's an
MCU character that makes the most sense
to appear alongside of uh Spider-Man if
that's part of the Sony contract which I
think it is I think Daredevil makes the
most sense and who the hell wouldn't
want to see that yeah that would be
awesome and especially if he doesn't
know it's Matt Murdock after Matt
Murdock was his lawyer who defended him
in no way home all right doesn't know
it's him yeah
no I mean I I
because because Tom Holland wouldn't
know
that
Daredevil and Matt Murdoch are the same
yeah okay yeah yeah okay yeah yeah
and then and then Matt Murdoch just
would have no idea
of course Mr blind man
how can you see so good a resident nerd
man thank you so much did you guys hear
gun officially cast Nick Cage as
Superman and Batman what a win ah you
think I fall for such a thing John do
your do your Nicholas Cage impression do
you bleed you will
I do a Superman line
I'm a big fan of Justin you went with
the just we didn't
always man that's the canonical version
all right
so the account is going to continue
that's the one that the Warner Brothers
wants to hang their hat on so I'm a I'm
a show for the WB did she yes dude yeah
I think the April Fool's thing is funny
um some people really hate it it just it
just freaked me out of my I think it
depends I can I can fall for some [__]
though sure I yeah I fell for one this
morning Thanos dizzy Plus show coming
I think we should do just like a Thanos
home renovation show where it's just him
like at his Hut making making fixes
mayank
uh thank you so much for the stupid chat
uh John why don't you read it my friend
hey hi Greg and John hello from India
hello to India huge fan here my question
is what's the future of one of them
majors in the MCU given the recent
events uh that's the question and there
isn't yet an answer because we just
don't know unfortunately and and the
latest batch of uh recasting with Bill
skars
wait yeah just throw up anyways that
have him play every villain from here on
yeah uh yeah I mean it is certainly
right now it seems like they're just
taking everything under consideration
and if it turns out that uh he can't
that it is
guilty Beyond A Reasonable Doubt then
they're gonna recast and if not then
they won't
yeah
um I think that John when I said this
this is two minutes
Oh I thought that was like two seconds
finger things okay okay and uh timings
yeah and I'm just going to say it out
loud so everyone know I don't want to
lie to you guys how the sausage is made
this means this means
once one minute you're making a great
point please continue
I don't know if anybody actually saw it
the the the I mean yeah for Jonathan
Majors I think wait till it plays out
and see what happens because I I don't
it's such a divide right now I think if
you go on Twitter
it will be very easy to believe that
everyone feels like the text messages
just prove that Jonathan Majors is
abusive and if you saw our video the
yesterday you know like even for us
we're like I can understand how one side
would believe this proves was innocent
and the other side would completely
believe this proves he's an abusive
[__] yeah right like it can either
one can be proven they can't hear the
tone of voice in this text so and I'm
telling you it was definitely alarming
for us as well but you know no we're not
we're right now with the like we'll if
they have a video I'd rather just wait
for that yeah I think that Johnny Depp
trial really just put everything in a
different role before we believe
anything let's just wait to hear yeah
yeah yeah yeah before we conclude we
should really wait it out a little bit
well yeah because at least that that
trial taught us how ugly and messy and
gray all this stuff can't be so yeah
it's like you really don't the court of
public opinion doesn't know any better
than the people with the actual evidence
even if they are trying to spin out
evidence so I I think right now the way
it's going about it to try to like
instantly do damage control is not smart
PR standpoint not smart it's not
creating the alleviation I believe there
are conversations happening uh I I
wouldn't be surprised that I think they
should be having conversations about
what are we doing daily and and honestly
you know with with it being Multiverse
and variants and all that [__] like I
think you can recast uh worst case as
great as he is as king
um I I totally think you can throw
Michael I think you can recast to me
it's not the flash situation where they
already spent all this money and they
filmed it and everything and yeah you
can't just reshoot that [__] you know oh
yeah and worst case if somebody did come
in with a new face that would at least
lead to a big old surprise yeah in in
real time watching the movie I think
just get the whitest skinniest guy you
can find uh Ginger geeked happy birthday
to you my friend hey happy birthday to
you Nicholas Pages Bruce Wayne face
that's coming or James Corden is
Clayface also a perfect casting Choice
yes definitely uh second James Corden
good I like the Leaky face Vengeance the
main thing that Spider-Man has going for
it and Sony is the is the uh the
spider-verse films man yeah
um oh apparently there's a basketball
game and that's why all these trailers
are dropping I don't know [__] that
yeah we gotta tune into the basketball
game we gotta find some way to get nerds
to tune into this sporting event well
you know I used to think about that like
is that what they're trying to do get us
to tune in but I think it's mainly to
appeal to all the people who don't
follow this stuff regularly yeah we're
gonna slip this nerd [__] into your
basket because once in a while I do
catch something that's randomly on
someone else's television if I'm over
the place and I'm like oh let's go uh so
I should watch more basketball
say on it works both ways thank you for
the Super Chat my friend uh thank you
for everyone who's here uh please leave
a like if you're if you're if you
haven't done so already because
um yeah that helps with the playback I
think it almost big contributoring Super
Chat uh Sean what's up Greg and John bit
of fans is 500k right around there I
decided I'm gonna be a fan
of clout that I can commit to fandom I
wish I could have saw you guys at
WonderCon uh it's okay next time you're
here giving a very generous Super Chat
that means way more yeah what's your top
five worst TV shows you've ever seen
sending them all the way from Dallas
funny enough I met a guy at the gym
today Josh who's from Houston
um anyway
the top five worst TV shows I've ever
seen I don't know what the work I've
never stuck it out with a worse TV show
never just been like this is garbage I
have to finish this we've even done that
on patreon like there's been shows that
were just like this is even though
people are watching at our patreon I'm
like was not driving for us like we're
just not enjoying it yeah remember
criteria for shows that we cover the
main three criteria is are we genuinely
interested in it
um will are and will our audience be
interested in it and how much traction
will it bring it you know yeah
um so that's like the the three
the three areas you want to try to hit
for for us we but we always do start
with are we interested
um but I could tell you some of the most
disappointing
endings for me that I've experienced
with TV because there's I would say
both endings of Dexter the rebooted
ending and the actual and the first
ending and the actual ending
um Game of Thrones is a sad experience
overall and uh those reaction that was a
really sad experience and that that that
makes me go like too I want to commit to
a re-watch
um I know yeah Hill is gonna crash I
didn't hate Iron Fist to disagree that
everyone else hated it but I think when
you put it in the influx of so many
great hits
uh like you know Luke Cage Daredevil and
Jessica Jones that's a real bummer
um and God you know I I think
I can't really think of uh yeah like I
said I I'm willing to quit a show if it
ain't working for me especially yeah in
the past several years it's it's to that
point we're just like yeah if I'm not
invested in this there's not all the
time in the world so I'll go look at
something else uh yeah I mean God I wish
I had a better answer to this question
it's true like uh the ending of Game of
Thrones certainly comes to mind the
ending of like the endings of things
like uh you know how How I Met Your
Mother or a Walking Dead certainly was
the first show that I actually that was
the first show where I like had the
moment with myself where I was like you
know what
I'm gonna stop that I used to love this
and now I I can just feel myself going
through the motions apparently it got
like amazing that's what I've after like
several foreign
supernatural has like a banger 11 season
and I think people were saying it's like
10 or 11 for Walking Dead where they're
like no they got a New Soul Runner it's
freaking great now yeah and and part of
me is always like maybe I'll just jump
back in on on I'll just skip some of
those seasons and just go to this and uh
I don't know if it would be a goddamn
Rick movie it's apparently still on the
table and they have like new Walking
Dead spin-offs coming to HBO
so maybe
okay it's a secret well I mean that's
our answer for that there's not really
anything if I come up with more
disappointing shows I'll let you know I
mean Jessica Jones certainly petered out
and got pretty tedious and that was a
bummer because the season's in the first
one was so good yeah yeah yeah I'm
trying to think if there was any like
particularly wretched Pilots or anything
like that at least I think book of Boba
Fett in retrospect is is a weird
disappointing experience when you had
Decades of figures yeah and made all the
more disappointing by the fact that
there is good work in it and it's so
misshapen that it yeah it doesn't really
uh honor that um but Luis Morales uh I I
can answer this one um are you guys
going to watch Superman and Lois I'm
assuming for season three I appreciate
the inquiry here Luis and of course a
Super Chat asking about it uh for
Superman and Lois season three well it's
funny enough we were we were just
bringing up what we were saying our
criteria is recovering shows because you
know I don't know what the there's been
some changes happening here but behind
the scenes like we've uploaded
significantly less and after evaluation
of how not only how much stuff we put
out last year but also how
um
how like mentally and emotionally uh can
be affecting like when the camera's not
rolling especially but then also how it
can bleed into camera you know I feel
like a big part of what happened with
Brooklyn Nine-Nine and why we ended up
losing viewership I've noticed like for
there's a solid period where people were
like Greg looks bored I'm like no the
truth is I'm just really [__] tired
and you know I can still enjoy something
really tired but I'm not going to be as
expressive because I'm tired I'm like
that in real life when I'm more tired
I'm probably not going to be as
expressive in conversation like it's
just the way it goes and for Superman
and Lois
as much as we really enjoyed that show
it just it's plain and simple for like
the 16 with the 10 to 16 weeks or
whatever it's like 16 week commitment or
something like that yeah it simply just
did not generate both seasons but
especially the second season did not
generate the viewership you know like
we're interested in it generates the
viewership and then it's like okay I can
commit like the extra hours to editing
and but it won't really pay off in the
end because it'll be like so many more
extra hours and the other part sometimes
that we do is like okay but you know
it's like is it getting are the watch
alongside our patreon getting that much
are we getting a good conversion there
because
in order to balance everything that that
happens here because to be totally
honest with you guys like there's been
there's plenty of days and there's a
period I worked every day up until the
day before my wedding you know and
there's a lot of times where I'll be
working like
because a lot of the making the editing
and thumbnails even if we get people who
uh like we have prepper who helps us
edit
we're still very much involved on the
re-edits for those things and a lot of
times that can be so much extra time and
the most important thing that it tends
to come down to for this channel is oh
yeah but when we're filming we have to
be like alive you know yeah and that can
that can greatly affect the experience
of Superman Lois on top of that too with
not many people were just watching at
our patreon we'd have like a
consistently eight to nine people at our
patreon watching it and as much as we
enjoyed the show the interest is just
not as like for the people who were
watching the same consecutive people
bottom line is like I was definitely
invested in getting editors to help out
with that one and didn't even break even
on that investment and so I kind of have
to pay attention to that personally
because I gotta make sure
all the guests who we bring on here the
regulars that I get to pay them I got to
make sure John gets paid I gotta make
sure the editors get they're gonna make
sure everyone's getting paid and then
also you know I
if you were look at my bank account
right now I there's like a real rejects
bank account because I had to set it up
as a business and I don't really pay
myself I
um I pay myself for what I need to for
my living expenses basically like I pay
myself just enough to but I also want to
make sure everyone else is getting paid
so I know it's kind of a convoluted
answer but there's a lot that factors in
into do we commit to this for 16 weeks
and what was the experience like and did
it and then okay ultimately with doing
the analytics on this yeah like both
seasons it just it actually ended up as
much as I enjoyed the show it was
did not even break even on the
investment for it which is which I just
got to face reality on something like
that and eventually you sometimes just
get to a position but I'm just going to
be honest with you guys like this is a
conversation a lot of YouTubers have and
I normally don't feel comfortable
discussing this because it sounds I
understand that there can be one version
of this that can sound like Greg just
thinking about views and money I'm like
well not yes there is a factor to that
but yeah but I am also thinking of well
the work versus reward on this will not
really be a pay like I'll pull an
all-nighter for Mandalorian because I
know it's going to do well yeah
it's about that investment but Superman
and Lois will like that'll if I'm
editing it you know those will take me
like three to four hours to edit than
making the thumbnails will take like
another hour and then then at the end of
it all I'm like okay well that's made
like
forty five dollars yeah yeah
it just yeah in in the grand scheme of
things it's kind of like dropping a rock
in your boat a little bit and you always
hope that you know it'll it'll and then
when you put all that in perform well
but when you put all that investment and
time and energy into it and then you
don't get it it actually can affect the
viewing experience well then that's the
weird part and I hate when that happens
with that when that affects the
enjoyment because I will enjoy it more
just watching on my own especially with
the show as good as that because also
too it's like it's a really great show
it's really fun to watch and then it's a
bummer when more people don't join in
with us to have the experience because
then it's like oh you know like what are
we doing wrong because we're not we're
not helping people some people really
like I remember like we didn't cover
Doom Patrol and people like well Doom
Patrol is failing then you're not
helping by not covering it and I'm like
well to be honest with you we we're not
part of the promo people who watch our
[__] after they're already watching it
yeah
it's not people going wow I watched all
these reactions now I'll go check this
show out now that I know all that's
gonna happen yeah yeah yeah
um because yeah one one metric that we
have for it is okay is it doing well on
our patreon at least and then we'll keep
it going but I was like oh only like
eight to nine people are watching this
on our patreon yeah this is like that's
not good numbers yeah
um so yeah after a while you do got to
make that choice to just scrap it but
you know at the same time like I said
there have been shows that at our
patreon that we were covering that we
liked that that we were not liking but
people were watching but because we
weren't liking it we were like we gotta
can it because we're not liking it
um yeah it's not translating into it
it's criteria I wanted to give a
detailed answer on that because I know
there's been like uh they're getting
that comment a lot so I'm just going to
clip that portion out and then release
it somewhere let me make a time around
the 50 minute Mark in this stream
alrighty guys well thank you um but
thank you guys for listening hearing me
out on that crooked
um thank you so much for the Super Chat
have we given up on Andrew Garfield
having another solo Spider-Man movie did
morbius kill that feel I could kill that
possibility John I spent a long time
explaining Superman Lois thing why don't
you answer that question for Cricket
thank you for the Super Chat sure uh I
certainly don't think morbius helped
that although I guess I would say for my
own view of the situation that a third
Andrew Garfield Spider-Man solo outing
has always felt like another one of
those uh unprecedented events I know
everyone was really riding high off
Spider-Man no way home and everything
they were able to achieve with that and
honoring his character there and I I
certainly think that the possibility
Still Remains that he could on the suit
again but like any any announcement of
an Andrew Garfield Amazing Spider-Man 3
to me would be like a pretty solid
surprise like they're building this
thing with Tom Holland still and I do
think that while there is that level of
enthusiasm for Andrew Garfield and Toby
McGuire they've talked to him as well
about coming back certainly the whole
Spider-Man Amazing Spider-Man 3 or or
Spider-Man 4 stuff is very much and I'll
believe it when I see it kind of thing I
believe they would make an appearance
sooner than they would actually invest
hundreds of millions of dollars into
continuing a franchise that's already
you know been
you know kind of had the the the the Box
shut on it it's funny because you know
as James Gunn is trying to get this DC
Universe uh in line because he's like
dude you got this timeline you got this
timeline you got this we got a we gotta
find a way to streamline some of this
you know to make one specific timeline
and then have an elsewhere thing going
on right
it's funny that with Spider-Man no way
home
they landed themselves in a position
where they easily could have done all
three Spider-Man movies they could have
done all three uh Spider-Man four with
Toby Maguire uh uh so uh Amazing
Spider-Man 3 and continue Tom Holland's
yeah they because no way home was a
massive success and they made it crystal
clear that each individual story lines
for them yeah and I think audiences
would tune in for each one of those
movies especially after no way home like
you they had a they have a gold mine on
their hands that they could have really
capitalized and hone in on but it seems
like they're making no real effort or
plans to go through with that which is
pretty pretty insane to me because that
they're the the thing that James Gunn is
concerned about with the DC Universe I'm
like well Spider-Man the universe
actually wouldn't have that problem it
wouldn't be it wouldn't be confusing for
people yeah because there's no way home
made it clear yeah yeah exactly I mean
yeah I I guess my question then would
just be like what is the restriction
from the Marvel side I feel like that
would be the biggest red screw that
Victoria Alonso ruin everything because
you want to promote a weird movie or
something sure yeah Marvel directs these
movies Corey Handler from New Orleans
thank you so much for being here Corey
or yeah yeah Louisiana and Sarah
Williamson also right there that's good
here that's good to hear
playing
um ah you guys recognize me from patreon
of course I didn't think you would haha
yeah you're just numbers to us at our
patreon number 5042.
asking as we're a week out what do you
think will get out of Star Wars
celebration any movies finally more TV
shows I don't know man lucasfilm is in a
weird [__] situation man we'll just
get more canceled projects
um yeah I I have no idea
best we're canceling here's everything
not to look forward to that would be
hilarious
um that's for today they should do that
today I think we're gonna get more
official acolyte announcements because
they're in the process of getting all
these directors and I mean have they
started filming acolyte have they I know
they're talking a lot about it
Skeleton Crew is the one with you yeah
and the Daniels are doing one and so oh
that's what's happening am I confused
about that I I don't remember which one
Jude Law is in is he still believe that
his Skeleton Crew and then the Downs are
being quartered for that not acolyte
yeah they did they've at least done I
think it's already shot one episode of
the of uh skeletons but is it that I
think we'll finally get and I think
Ahsoka trailer will actually drop online
uh I feel like it'll be in conjunction
my prediction is that Mandalorian season
three will have an episode that features
Ahsoka since that are deciding to
introduce all the Star Wars Rebels in
there so I think it'll have
um Ahsoka and then
um
and then after around that time whatever
plot line we get then we can get an
Ahsoka trailer that makes sense yeah
yeah that's uh especially as they're
quite teasing all these uh Rebels
characters because like the space whale
I always read the day with them with the
space spells in episode one massive part
of the finale of Star Wars Rebels and
then of course uh Zeb being introduced
and
after thrawn being mentioned in season
two
and uh I don't think she there's any
name of Ezra mentioned uh but you know
Ezra Bridger is supposed to be in
at Ahsoka show I believe so yeah uh I
don't know I don't think they're gonna
announce any movies I do holiday special
I really think the time for Kathleen
Kennedy
time for Kathleen Kennedy to end uh I I
think the time of Kathleen Kennedy
leaving will probably come a little bit
after
uh Indiana Jones
I think it's um yeah let the current
projects ride out oh the pasta kill it
if you have to
um oh that's interesting to hear about
Daredevil Born Again taking place during
and after the blip I like that actually
I've heard that's that being an
explanation as to maybe why foggy and
Karen are back well yeah I mean they
also uh
or has there been a newer development I
don't know doesn't matter I hope they'd
bring back that election she was amazing
hey Bad Medicine thanks for being here
bud
or is it buds thanks for being here
Chris Rock is scarecrow
that's an all right stand up special oh
did you watch it I watched the Marlon
Wayans one
that's who you went with you didn't
watch the Chris Rock one did you really
choose the Marlon Wayans stand up over
the Chris Rock stand up I mean not in
those direct I wasn't sitting there
going which one do I watch I just happen
to have watched the Marlon Wayans one
you didn't even bother to check out the
Chris Rock one I mean I heard the clip
of him talking about Will Smith and all
that stuff
this was like the most anticipated stand
of all time and it was okay and that's
what I heard that's why I was like I'll
watch the clip and then eventually if
I'm really that compelled I'll go watch
the whole specials okay and I thought it
was a prior one was brilliant okay
whatever the first Netflix one he did I
thought that was brilliant okay uh let's
see here that one instead Bad Medicine
is the [__] subscribe to Bad Medicine if
you guys haven't done so already it will
be worth your time and money absolute
vodka Adam Sandler as Magneto I love it
I don't have to bear metal
or Ash cows
um Johnny thank you so much for the
Super Chat my friend oh John God
specifically oh your top five directors
today and top five of all time I'm
putting a timer on you or else we'll be
here forever yeah I don't know this is
gonna be tricky uh 90 seconds to speak
from your subconscious best director's
working right now I like Panos cosmoto's
a lot I like like uh uh I mean I always
enjoy in a great joint um
um on the spot it's so hard come on John
uh I'm trying to think of movies I I've
enjoyed speak from your heart um
um uh it's uh
you guys one minute John I I'm not I I
would have to look
um yeah you panic Under Pressure don't
do it yeah my mind is clear Don't Panic
Under Pressure John I'm trying not to uh
um do you like Quentin Tarantino I like
Quentin Tarantino right yes you said
Edgar Rodriguez I always like a
Rodriguez joint really okay do you like
Christopher Nolan yeah Christopher
Nolan's great
stay Adventure
is yeah I'm in big respect I already
asked I don't really claim him as a fave
uh res is great uh I don't like have
that like uh got a John Carpenter is is
certainly one sure
um
a female director but I I don't know who
to who to pull they don't direct movies
my producers dude the male ones yes
that's true that's right
Karen kusama I do I do like her stuff a
lot
um
we'll go there for right now bam is his
name ten directors for John you're good
and he said like he likes you're much
you're much better at off the doming
those kinds of things than me I need to
like look up my I need to look up and
there's no time to think you just go
from the heart
um yeah I'll I'll learn your skills
pressure creates diamonds it can
or it makes you shrink up it's one of
the two I mean pressure clears my head
out and then I'm and that's when I re
that's the irony I'm like why couldn't
you be here when I was meditating
um Heather couldn't my head be clear
then uh Heather gear thank you for being
here
um super sad I wasn't local to make your
panel oh it's okay you could have driven
someone drove 10 hours just to it they
literally arrived and then left
WonderCon after 10 hours and I thought
that was incredible and he had such a
great girlfriend uh because she drove
the whole way and I know she certainly
seemed like she did that for him I bet
she had no idea who we were
and she and I love seeing that Dynamic
for like the two Live Events we've done
recently I love seeing when someone has
a significant other and the significant
other has no clue who we are yes
um anyway she asks do you think the mid
and does she gets you care you care too
much to get Danny Boyle there you go you
care too much
there's like a worry that I think that
you're not you're not saying you're not
giving the proper answer and I think
you're lean to me yeah it's like I want
to give the answer that I feel is
spiritually right for me but I also want
to give an answer I think is a good
answer like a quality answer because I
don't know if I'm just like naming Rando
directors then I don't feel good I think
you have a fear that kicks in and that
fear is what creates this blockage it
could be but if you lead with love oh
it's so much easier to find that answer
okay that's why I mean my come from the
heart okay because you'll find it from
there instead of like am I oh uh uh
people were mean to me growing up what
do I do that's what I was thinking about
when I was thinking about these
directors I was like who was there for
me when people were mean Danny Boyle
that's who's there for me another gears
uh do you think the mid end credits are
still enjoyable for the MCU DC EU
uh they
what was I I think black panther would
kind of forever
weirdly has been washed away
even for me
when I like talk about what Marvel's
been like lately I'm like oh yeah I
forgot I love that movie and that was
one of the more recent ones yeah
um
and you know the Henry Cavill one was
pretty awesome
they're they're still like corny and
cheesy and sequel setups sure
uh but I think they're still fairly
enjoyable uh I don't hate them like the
the DC one is the first Shazam Fury of
the Gods was a little crunchy sure
last one a little cringy sure yeah you
know how we felt about the King Dynasty
certainly it is one of those where they
are requisite now so there isn't
the spontaneity so much but they're so
fun and excited because there's still
that there's still mystery boxes because
you know that they will likely one will
have some odd to do with the movie and
then one will likely be toward the
future but like you know the without
going too specifically even though
probably everyone's seen quantumania
like the post post credits a bit I was
very excited about uh and I thought was
like a really cool little scene so like
yeah it happens it's just now I just a
clip I don't think those really count
it's like we had some low-key footage
it's the equivalent of playing a trailer
to me it is you know for sure and and
what was the movie where they showed the
doctor strange Multiverse Madness yeah
so like yeah like I don't care as much
for that philosophy yeah I did enjoy
that scene so yeah it's like it's I I
think the sheen is a little bit
dispelled now but I think I think uh
I'll give myself 30 seconds here I think
the the point with um just uh to go off
of the point here sure is it's been a
while since it's been a while it's been
a while since we had a post credits like
I love the Black Panther one because
we're kind of forever because it was so
emotional it felt like a real scene that
added to the ending of transmission
whereas but the last time there was a
big credit scene didn't just feel like
yeah that makes sense yeah sure that's
what's going to happen yeah like if
Henry Cavill wasn't ruined that would
have had more of that effect for sure I
can imagine the people who didn't know
about it were like oh my god
um but when it comes to uh the last one
that really was like holy [__] was I
think Spider-Man far from home sure when
Peter Parker and Jameson and yeah and uh
he's Spider-Man yeah that that was the
last one where it was like
everything that just happened has been
completely flipped upside down
I can't wait for this next Spider-Man
movie what are they gonna do yeah
that was the last one where I but now a
lot of times you're like all right
cool
yep yeah you need one yeah yeah
absolutely it's just yeah they're
requisite now it's like if you don't get
a mid in a post-credits scene now I feel
like you'd walk out going what happened
there
um thank you guys again for being here
really means a lot uh Deadshot is asking
and um yeah
how intrigued are you about The Flash
movie since Tom Cruise love it
not gonna lie it it does do something
outside of movies are you ready for
mk-12 trailers soon oh Jesus oh boy
they're making the new MK how do you get
into the storyline
it's been wow uh we got six sixes
uh yeah John you didn't really get a
comment about this I talked about it
last stream
um so how do you feel about Tom Cruise
loving the flash good I mean it
certainly seems like Tom Cruise is an
agent of Cinema I don't think he has any
reason to do this you know out of a
contrivance of any kind it seems like if
he heard it was great and got a copy and
said it was great it's probably pretty
great I don't know like unanimously
everyone was like this movie is great so
unless there's some kind of shadowy
conspiracy where people are like we just
need this movie to make money please uh
you know that's very heartening I I
think there is some weight though too
about him calling Andy machete what do
you think oh absolutely yeah I mean that
suggests again like if that really
happened I think that's a lovely thing
uh because yeah that that shows
especially from somebody like Tom Cruise
I can just imagine he's like no I gotta
let you know how great this is you know
and uh and yeah like and I that makes me
really happy for Andy Mushi Yeti
especially because of how difficult the
road this has been and you know like I
am rooting for him to you know level up
again you know with this movie from you
know Mama to it to this so
oh he did Mama didn't he am I or was it
Ma no no no no no
no but uh but yeah I think mama is a
mushy Eddie joint yeah
uh that's right yeah when he was going
by Andres still
oh
oh yeah back in the DIA that's right and
somewhere along the line is his
publicist in America it's like we need
you to be more of a
universally appealing name
we don't want people thinking this is a
Mexican movie we want them to know
Andy's is more relatable than uh Andres
puts you into a corner yes yes of course
that's right it's super Americans we
don't know what to do or like are we
gonna pronounce this wrong is you
somehow hoity toity director right Andy
everyone knows an Andy to this day is
his schwartzen Slimer uh no one knows
how to pronounce Arnold's last name just
works in Slimer is my favorite
Ghostbusters character
[Laughter]
always watching so good to see you here
don't worry we'll be watching DND
Sandman will forever be on the list
maybe when season two comes out we'll
watch it and then have a Witcher
experience where season two ends up
being hated uh Netflix is dark is
something that has been considered for a
certain for certain it's been considered
yeah people love dark and they have been
taught I've heard people talk about it
consistently for years yeah yeah I do
want to watch it man thank you oh no
yeah at least finish out season four and
let's see how that goes very least we'll
see
bigots have started to forget that Civil
War was titled Captain America movie
while being Avengers
that's right man
I love that
um
super soldier ship in the Incredible
Hulk girl
my favorite part of live streams when
I'm reading just reading these to myself
without reading them out loud it's okay
because now I'll recite the directors
again
take it away John do it super quick okay
so the director's working right now I
would say it's Jordan Peele Robert
Eggers Denise Villeneuve ariaster and
Tarantino for the auteur veteran status
and then personals I would go Panos
cosmoto's Danny Boyle John Carpenter
Karen kusama right
you say that Tarantino thing as if he's
not an amazing director he is an amazing
director this is one of those pulls it's
an obvious pull that like you know
everyone kind of feels like well of
course you chose Tarantino and Rodriguez
a lot he's really hit or miss he's Hit
or Miss but I like his I I like how him
all of it is whereas like there are
certain people who make a miss and I'm
like ah this is just a Nothing Cake
where it's like a Robert Rodriguez Miss
is still filled with flavors sure even
if it doesn't work crooked
um my God what is wrong with his Mouse
um oh and one more thing don't want to
spoiler for John who she is but Florence
Pugh as Abby in Last of Us season two
please oh my God uh I do like that pick
even though people say she's too old I
like a lot the choice like I was
thinking about it when watching
Mandalorian whoever that woman is with
Pershing in episode uh oh yeah yeah
um um I don't know that actress's name
but she's great she's also an Ant-Man
quantity
oh something I think she would be a
fantastic pick Katie O'Brien I mean
she's got the build and she's very
believable and they're she's got enough
quality she doesn't look a lot like um
as Abby but I think she'd be a good pick
but yeah we shouldn't really talk too
much about this uh let's see your city
boy is it a boy
uh do you think reverse flash is going
to be in The Flash movie I do not think
reverse flash is going to be in the
movie
I don't know maybe it could be
steal the opportunity for Ezra to get to
do that so I think if you do recast Kang
I've seen the question come up a couple
of times in this chat as I've been
scrolling um I think if you do recast
King I think you should keep it with a
person of color sure yeah yeah I don't
think you should just make it a Whitey
wood Mighty Mike my Whitey or you go
with
um Jody Whitaker uh I would be here for
that I might as well make a king a woman
uh I I do think um I mean you could do
Sterling K Brown you could make it work
the cool thing is you could take someone
who's already died in the MCU and then
put them in there because Terence Howard
okay Terence Howard is King what a bold
move that would be holy crap that would
be insane
all kinds of questions for wait was Iron
Man one in a different Multiverse okay
just hide again
the whole time like why now and then did
he have to brainwash everybody and not
realize when the real Rodeo
um wait a minute we do have ourselves
Ace One stream lap to honor here hey we
must honor the stream Lab somebody in
the chat just going back to that
disappointed TV shows question Riverdale
I was enjoying up until the point I
stopped watching it so I ca even though
I've heard it goes downhill I I cannot
claim that myself
your phone oh your phone's ringing oh hi
John which one okay boom let me just uh
make everything really complicated here
do it the more complicated the better
that's what people say
I know we're not jabby Coe uh Sammy boy
thank you so much for the stream Lab hi
I hope you're having a great day you
know what
it could be better
could be could be we'll see maybe it
will get it I woke up
it's massive
um anyway I was wondering since we are
in the reboot long-awaited sequels era
has it been a success in your opinion or
just milking it I feel like Studios
don't care if the script is good if they
just get a profit well I
I I mean [__] top gun Maverick is uh
sensation
and it's that's such a crowd-pleasing
film it got nominated for an Oscar for
best picture and best screenplay
and uh is billion dollar box office
behemoth
I feel like that is I mean I feel like
there's been I think this this era has
made it worth it for films such as Top
Gun mapper that's a good way to put that
yeah because they're always Mining and
they're always you know coming back for
some Legacy I think right now we're in
an interesting point where you have
people
you have the sort of Remaining movie
stars who are also getting older who are
now sort of closing these loops and
bringing certain characters and Stories
full circle and I think that is a bit
unique as to as compared to what I've
been aware of in the past at least like
even something like a John Wick 4 feels
like sort of some kind of culmination
for movie star Keanu Reeves top gun
Maverick obviously a culmination for
movie star uh Tom Cruise so yeah I feel
like we have that extra element of like
emotional maturity going into some of
these but yeah I mean it's
the same milking process it's always
been and sometimes there are gems
all depends but thank you for asking
about that yeah uh let's see here
it's not Steve is is Russell T Davies I
think is taking back over from from
chibnol it's not it's not Stephen
Moffett I need to fix this this is a bob
Iger situation
how people are treating it
we just started season 11 over on or we
just finished season 11 over on patreon
too it wasn't as bad as everyone said it
would be yeah like the movie pixels
Jaime James 13. will you watch Dungeons
and Dragons honor among Thieves well
first off thank you for the Super Chat I
saw it every night with someone I
started dating and we both loved it and
then we fell in love and she made sweet
sweet love to me in a Jamaican accent
the entire night and we rolled the
20-sided dice to decide on position it
was all because of Dungeons and Dragons
that's right she would stand on top of
me and snare like a dragon
your best Benedict Cumberbatch and mocap
impression yeah uh we do we are gonna
watch it but uh probably not in the
theaters we have a very limited window
for when a movie reviewed as well
a very specific set of circumstances
really it's got to be like a couple days
ahead of time it's gonna be outside it's
gonna be a certain caliber of moving
it's gonna be a play Blockbuster of
sorts we don't have uh we're not one of
those channels that does well if we're
like ah we released this Saturday it
came out yeah
we didn't know well enough unfortunately
but Rick Michonne spin-off as well as a
Daryl spin-off overall thoughts on
Gotham I just want to put that out there
uh I thought Gotham was incredible
incredible
um were you guys embarrassed when Eric
Voss said making videos on Jonathan
major so soon was unethical just depends
on what the videos were I think if you
watch our videos on it I think we we I
genuinely think we have a pretty fair
way of doing it sure I don't think our
videos are disingenuous and I feel like
we're apt to be like hey it's a little
soon to be jumping to certain
conclusions you know so yeah it's really
all in how you handle it I mean some
might say or some people embarrassed
when they film a reaction video when
clearly they've already reacted to it
would they already watched it beforehand
you know like it's one way of saying it
uh yeah you know I don't know there's
lots of embarrassing circumstances in
the YouTube space that you could find
yourself in uh but Eric is a genius and
I if you haven't seen he's a really
really kind guy
um on the way to the to the live stream
that he did here with us
um and also I've seen a couple of his
videos for deep dive and they're great
they are great videos uh the low-key
ones pretty [__] amazing and I really
do love the live stream live stream that
uh we did here it's almost like 200 000
views yeah and it's got like a 45 minute
watch time mark this is the most longest
watch Time video I've ever had so Eric
to sit in the corner always uh we'll
review Mario Oppenheimer and Barbie
Mario
um I think we're gonna react reaction
I'm gonna react to that might as well uh
Oppenheimer theaters theaters theaters
Barbie
real back and forth uh I'm really back
and forth I don't know uh Barbie I'm
sorry feels like a reactor it does but I
also I'm like but Ryan Gosling right in
the theaters
you got to see those abs big
um yeah I see oh I see some muscles
under that Cape you're good oh you're
right you absolutely are seeing muscles
under that cave Alex see I survived the
April first fits a comic book cast where
they all trolls it can't be they some of
them are all they're all true
they're all true April fact day is what
we're celebrating now so John is getting
paid
is these oh no you John has mainly been
doing this at the kindness of his heart
that's right and this commitment
impoverished I just like being here
negatives and broke for years the IRS is
actively pursuing my whereabouts like
how come you bring no income ever
how do you have a straight zero income
constantly at a zero yeah you're not
even in the negative so you're just zero
solid zero yeah you know that's how I do
um damn it well thank you for the Super
Chat Alex see yeah leave comment with
your uh favorite of the April 1st comic
book cast April Fool's vids but uh thank
you guys again for I just want to keep
saying thank you to everyone who's here
to the chat if you haven't left a like
yet please go ahead and do that if you
have to bounce at any point if I can't
stick around for the whole thing please
hit the like that's if you want to leave
here you have to leave a like and please
go ahead and uh Muhammad we are are
factoring out some stuff I I think the
more time goes on with YouTube the more
direct and honest I get advertised I
slowly become just more more I've
already been a pretty transparent guy
and then now I'm like even more
transparent I think that's a good policy
because then people have a better idea
of what actually goes into all this
um
yeah no you can contribute to our
patreon or you can super chat or or get
one of our Zero edition shirts most sold
shirt our most recent one which I I'm
still waiting for the mail
um our most recent one uh the child
protection services shirt that is our uh
most sold shirt
um ever and it did it in 24 hours uh I
was like
normally we look at the 30-day window
and it's like this sold more than any
and then the other one's in 24 hours and
that that was really this is a good
feeling I was really proud of that uh
snow Shadows top five Batman villains in
order okay here we go we can do this
sure go from the heart all right I would
say uh I'm not sure let's try to count
backwards a little bit here
um look I'll get this out of the way
just so there's no big anticipation here
the cliche one is Joker and number one
for me is Joker it is Joker like at the
same time yeah like everyone else I'm
like please stop doing Batman and Joker
movies for a while let us miss the Joker
please but there's a reason Joker is one
of the most iconic characters of all
time and why he goes so hand in hand
with Batman like he is the best villain
for Batman and so yeah I love Joker
um
as much as I want to pull like odd ones
they're all bunch of people really do
know uh I do love Mr Freeze I think Mr
Freeze is an insanely compelling villain
and I'll rearrange the order in just a
bit
uh Deathstroke wall can be across the
board for a lot of people I do think
Deathstroke for hand-to-hand combat is
pretty incredible Moss is not in love
with racial ghoul the way other people
are so I don't know if I'd even include
him on the list
um
I weirdly like Mad Hatter Madhatter I
like Mad Hatter quite a lot
and there's like okay there's Killer
Croc Hugo it was strange
a Hugo Strange is pretty great okay so I
think for five I go Mad Hatter okay
four I go clay face oh fun three I go Mr
Freeze
yeah I'm also not like when I read
penguin in comics I'm not that drawn to
him okay but I do like him in on screen
a lot sure
uh we're gonna put Hugo straight did
everything five
two
oh I forget about the female ones like
poison ivy I love poison ivy I would put
poison ivy as three probably three for
me too yeah no you know I bumper to two
Mr Freeze at at three and then I put
um uh Joker at one okay yeah okay oh
yeah Joker uh scarecrow at number two uh
poison ivy [__] did I skip scary I've
come up with a whole story idea
surroundings characters
I've totally blank on scarecrow it's all
good there's some I think Batman has a
great Rogues Gallery yeah uh yeah so uh
Joker yeah I gotta swap out of Mad
Hatter sure sure uh uh and then poison
ivy
this is John list so I'll say uh
Phantasm and Solomon Grundy
nice yeah yeah it's not bad yeah yeah
and Phantasm is great yeah no offender
again that's such a great movie like
it's such a lovely wonderful movie yeah
I think he's got a great Rogues Gallery
but they're you know I was trying to
answer like who am I definitely drawn to
live action and Comics yeah and who
would I want to play with if I had the
opportunity yeah you know to write
um let's see here this sounds like an
April Fool's joke but I think it's legit
Tommy Wiseau has a film coming out
tomorrow called Big sharp by the way
would love to interview you guys again
oh thank you so much formerly peace oh
Spencer what's up buddy
um yeah you know I do
I wonder I haven't I've only done my
zone movie I've seen in his room yeah I
haven't seen the other ones because I
always wonder if it's gonna try to be
so bad it's good or is it gonna capture
that lightning in a bottle yeah I
thought the house would drip blood on
Alex short was pretty fun but it is in
that sort of like we're embracing the
meme kind of kind of caliber I mean like
this is a a film directed by hymns I
think so I mean and if it's got a shark
in it like that's not what I was
expecting at all so I mean I'm excited
to see I haven't seen the trailer yet
but I'm excited to see whatever
weirdness comes out of it like yeah I
haven't seen best friends I haven't seen
a lot of his other like random
appearances but yeah I mean if it's him
directing I have to imagine that it's
it's gonna it's gonna be tell me why so
Joey I would love to watch it yeah
that's true yeah I like it it seems like
it will have to be a strange and
interesting experience no matter what
okay yeah yeah yeah I might watch it who
knows
um full reaction maybe that's a big
maybe this is all we gotta check it out
giant list of things yeah let's go in
order of and I like doing the weekly
live streams this is the thing that I I
feel I really do enjoy the live streams
and and I want to make it a regular not
a daily thing but like a once a week
thing I think it's a really enjoyable
experience and it's kind of like uh
I don't know how to put it it's kind of
it's so there's such a process between
filming and editing and and uh whereas
here there is something that's like a a
refresher and a reset of
like a palette cleanser weird way I
don't know for the brain to just do a
live stream because it's it's just so
like off the cuff and personal and yeah
well we get to spend time directly with
you not like trying to cut or insert you
know yeah it's such a different uh it's
more I do I do enjoy it it makes it
it's it may it makes feel more connected
to to audience yeah I just love the
energy like live streams are so fun like
I'm I'm grateful to be here today
because uh yeah this is always a
highlight to join you guys live on a on
any day of the week Joker scarecrow
Riddler I like Riddler I do like River
I don't know there's something about
Riddler though that I I don't know I'm
not I'm not as in love I love Riddler
but I'm not he's not my top five for
some reason it's not the one I'm like
looking for yeah it's strange yeah and
I'm weirdly totally understand why they
constantly want to bring in for Live
Action even loved him in Gotham thought
it was excellent like my God what an
underrated performance uh and he was
like a series regular it was amazing and
I I understand why people love him so
much but at the same time
um you know
there's something about where I'm not
not like always the most even though
he's a I don't know now that I'm I feel
like I'm talking myself into it now
because even like the Batman games and
[__] I'm like you know what though
would you get Riddler right like when
you got when you get it right like it's
pretty he's pretty [__] compelling
sure game of mystery and kind of Mouse
um you have to yeah you just have to
have really smart writing around them
yeah yeah all right the more uh this is
really easy just uh watch watch that
happen
um so let's see here
oh that's a really nice way to put it 99
of the time when I try to be honest
about something like that PK Production
Studios it leads to insane backfire
thank you so much
yeah thank you
um tasm II killman when your film was
failure makers can we get a real Rejects
movie in the style of fablemans yes
I've always thought it'd be more like a
Michael gandry movie oh sure I think a
real Rejects Move would be more than
that yeah I haven't seen Be Kind Rewind
but I imagine it would be like that from
the trailer I remember being from my
vague recollection of I have seen Be
Kind Rewind and yes I think it would be
yeah in in in what I recall of it yeah
there does need to be a level of trust
with the audience we are Jack Black and
most deaf I appreciate that
um
thank you so much for the Super Chat my
friend thank you again the super chats
do not go underrated I'm under
recognized I mean thank you they're uh
definitely definitely do not take it for
granted enough like you're all like any
and all of your generosity is like very
you know none of you have to be here
contributing anything we get messages on
patreon and I really try to respond to
everyone and I'm often very late
um but for those who have messaged me on
patreon you'll know that I I do try to
respond so uh thank you
do you guys think do you think D guns
DCU will cater for comic book fans who
enjoy the more serious mature stuff like
me
I've lost that face with MCU I missed
movies like Logan The Dark Knight and
Man of Steel only have Reeves Batman
um
uh
you know
as much as there is a
a reverence and vulgarity in The Suicide
Squad there's also a lot of maturity to
it I think it depends on the property
that being said with the properties that
were announced I I feel like they they
will the voice of it will probably draw
there was this thing that came out
recently with Victoria about Victoria
Alonso and then how a director was
talking with this very credible reporter
about how Victoria Alonso pretty much
stated that like the directors don't
direct the movies we direct them and
that's something that I think most of us
already picked up on that it's very
committee driven with its films and
there was a great point of how that's
why they pick out these independent
filmmakers who have no experience with
visual effects films because it causes
you it's essentially like creating like
a codependent relationship or like we
don't really know what to do so we're
going to trust that you put it together
you know yeah and that's why a lot of
them end up kind of having the same look
to them uh not just in the visual
effects but kind of all around
and I think Gunn will let the director's
voice be more of the conversation in
conjunction with the filmmaking I feel
like the directors will be part of the
committee yes in a more vital way like
just the fact that he's embracing the
elseworld side off hand and and like
embracing Joker embracing the Batman
letting those exist
to me speaks volumes that he will also
help allow that
when it comes to I don't think they'll
just let him do whatever but I think I
think he'll help encourage to bring out
more of the unique voice per film yeah I
would agree with that yeah certainly and
I think that I I think that they will
definitely cater to and honor the you
know more mature side of the universe
but I think it will just be more in
proportion to what the comics actually
are which is you'll have a lot of stuff
that is a little bit more light a little
bit more of aspirational to younger
viewers but you will certainly have your
mature caliber stuff I just don't really
ever foresee it going into the direction
again where anytime soon where it's
mostly geared toward that mature dark
gritty kind of tone I feel like you
might not get as much but you will get
some sure sure
see the stopwatch helps it does yeah
create a stopwatch when it came to koi
doing his solo videos here yeah Cory
we're doing a ranking video you can't
talk for 10 minutes
to go through we could have 200 minute
ranking video yeah yeah yeah
but you know I feel like people's flag
comic book things that aim toward the
youth and I'm like that's why they were
invented to begin with and we shouldn't
lose sight of that but yeah also there
will be maturity depends per property I
don't think John should play extreme
Last of Us one because I I think that's
part of the the joy of
I should wait till the show's done yeah
yeah just to do any of that okay because
I don't think they're gonna continue it
um I don't think they're gonna continue
it uh uh after season two because I
think they're gonna divide season two in
a two seasons because the game is
forever
the first game is kind of short and the
second game is really low yeah
same game is a long time like when I
replayed the first one I beat it in a
weekend and then the second one I was
like uh assuming like at least a week
and a half to get through
um one then maybe then maybe by then
I'll have a PS5 to play off over okay
seven or whatever we're on because
lately I've been like okay how do I hook
my PS3 up to the TV first streaming
because even though part two is very
different I still feel like the cree it
will create a certain kind of
lens of comparison and watching
performance and I think that's part of
the joy of John and Tara's reactions to
that is you don't
they they have no true foundations yeah
um did talk about I can't wait for
stranger things season five I don't know
who's gonna die I don't think they like
killing off people
um I gave a very long detailed answer MJ
to Superman and Lois coverage yeah can't
go through it again
um
Andrew mirik
ooh interesting
what do you guys think of Grace
Randolph's hate towards Jessica Chastain
well thank you for the Super Chat I
think it's funny yeah I'm gonna report
you for child abuse
I I think I think it's funny
sure because it's become a meme in it of
itself but I find more interesting is
the James Gunn like I I want to say this
I don't I don't like YouTube beefs and I
know I make fun of like pretty much
everyone when it comes to Grace Randolph
we've briefly chatted we get along and
and uh she's been very kind to to me
especially on on all accounts and I've
uh whatever jokes I make just trust me
they're all in fun jest they're never in
like I'm trying to tear this person down
and I do that about a lot of YouTubers
but I know Grace Randolph can often be a
Target especially on Twitter uh but I do
find it more fun when I'm like oh
something about James gun disagreeing
with her [__] because yeah he's gonna
jump in there right like so many of
these people you get the sense that this
maybe this will get back to them but I
don't know not even that seems unlikely
or is James Gunn he's gonna be the
talking direct well I mean yeah I know
James Gunn has definitely had his issues
with with Grace like he's made some
serious and there was something recently
with like Dylan O'Brien being cast and
then he quote tweeted not in a nasty way
he was just saying like I don't even
know who this person is yeah yeah and
then he followed up being like okay okay
yeah I looked him up and I've seen him
before but because of the history of
Prior interaction of like a real insult
that he threw at grace before yeah it
you know led to that again she often
goes trending and it's usually not
usually for some kind of controversy but
my direct inner any kind of interaction
or even public speaking with her and I
has always been it's been positive so
yeah I'm I don't but I I think the meme
itself of Grace hate Grace Randolph
hating to Jessica Chastity and I I don't
I have a weird thing where I have a very
difficult time with
um Peter sarsgaard sure uh sleepy eyes
something about him where once in a
while he does a performance from like
you know what you were good I thought
you were one of the best parts of that
Green Lantern movie but more often than
not on like more often than not I'm like
I don't get why you get work
he's watching the stream right now he's
about to go tweet you and this is my
opinion and I just made it I made a joke
out of it because it's uh
because I know that I'm I I can also
the first movie I saw me was Kenzie but
at the same time I don't
I don't have a genuine hate for the guy
sure sure she's a joke to me yeah yeah I
think I I think it kind of borders on uh
you know it's yeah it's just like this
guy has his thing his look and it's not
for me yeah yeah which is uh it's funny
enough I know a few people who feel that
way about Jessica's Chastain in
particular daisha's always watching
what's up thank you for for taking a
break from John Wick to join us
uh John Wick reaction
um always watching what's up Roby I know
we we are divisive here when it comes to
the King Dynasty mid credit scene the
idea is cool the execution is
funky
um be funky fresh uh Johnny
favorite movie thank you for being here
and for contributing uh favorite movie
genre and favorite movie theater food
favorite movie genre what's your
favorite movie genre my favorite
umbrella is horror horror movies of all
varieties are usually My my what I am
compelled toward
is that is that what's your favorite
movie theater food Johnny
clap I mean you know we didn't grow up
having the movie theater food so when I
started like really going to the cinema
with you and like you know when I let go
of that like just the Classic popcorn
has become such a like when you get good
movie theater popcorn ain't nothing like
it uh but you know aside from that like
I don't know I I I I like the classics I
don't I don't need necessarily like one
of those AMC's where they're bringing
you like a four course meal so it's like
if it's not uh popcorn then it's like a
hot dog or a nacho or something like
that you know the classics both times
I've seen John Wick I did not get
popcorn and that was tough I know
it's just the hardest I think out of the
the biggest challenge of eating
healthier these past few weeks has been
saying no to popcorn at theaters sure
that's been the hardest part it's such a
habit yeah just want to learn
but now I pack like healthy snacks and
become that you become Andrew become
that loser you become Andrew who's like
you're like keto cereal yeah
he was a kiwi slice let's go or whatever
it happens to be yeah yeah
um yeah I've become that guy but uh now
I sneak Topo Chicos into the theater but
but it is hard it is hard to say no
because I love I love popcorn at
theaters it's a perfect experience yeah
especially when you get a good like
that's why I missed the Arc Light they
had such good popcorn and the Lemley and
nose going away they got good popcorn I
remember I think we saw a test screening
for Al Pacino documentary called Salome
and I just I have this weird memory of
young Greg and John and their teens yeah
and just looking over at John and how he
was eating popcorn back in the day
yeah though
I just get a big handful
I gotta Flex
me try to offset the calories by by
flexing it up a little bit never
forgotten the image you're just looking
over it's this big I know and and now
whenever I grab like a few kernels and
it's like you know you get that that
that finger full where like there's just
unwieldy kernels sticking to each other
and now I'm like am I going back to that
away it was like a cartoonishly like you
put a guy in a fat suit
yeah man you've taught me how to eat
theaters you've taught me how to
breatheners he really shaped me as a
movie goer and I appreciate it it's for
the better of all audiences
40x screenings lately and it is it is
surprisingly hard to keep a hold of
popcorn in that environment
I love the AMC commercials
people with their popcorn yeah yeah
at that point if I'm leaning in I'm not
going to be like eating much more you're
not going to be hugging the barrel my
freshman or when they're watching a film
in the trailers something spooky happens
I'm like I've never done that today
I don't think I've ever even seen that
happen yeah they have infomercial hands
where just like anything happens and
they're just like whoa the popcorn it's
everywhere I just dump it on the person
yeah
it looks magical
yeah man and uh and of course uh just I
love people applauding I feel like you
know uh they gotta next time have uh
what's her name correct Nicole kimmons
she doesn't eat at the theater she's not
throwing her popcorn she'll take after
Nicole I know she rents out the whole
theater like a [__]
like an elite this is the best way to
experience
thousands of dollars for Sam the manly
thanks to the Super Chat Charlie Sheen
is Wolverine that'd be nuts oh cool
uh Sam the man lean you're all's list
from cameos for Secret Wars I could list
this off in five seconds everyone
everyone
will be in secret Wars it'll be at the
point where if they're not in it the
movie will be rendered disappointing I'm
thinking get Dolph Lundgren's Punisher
yeah in there oh Hasselhoff's Nick Fury
yeah now I'm serious do it do it all
just make room for just one giant
spinning shot yeah so Eric Voss can have
a field day of trying to point everyone
out Italian Spider-Man all of it do it
I'm not even kidding just usually one
shot who played Captain
and they're all Canon Captain America
movie just one shot everyone kind of Tom
Cruise Iron Man do it one shot yeah
that's all you need yeah yeah
um thanks babe for letting me now uh doe
eyes who do you think will be revealed
as a scroll and oh no
oh no John
have we lost it oh no oh no
no no John no no no no no oh we got it
we got it we're good oh
we think we'll Beville is a scrolling
secret Invasion everyone
Tom Cruise Iron Man Nick Fury David
Hassel
uh you mean that's part of the fun of
the secret Invasion comic run to my
understanding
so who's been a scroll all this I think
I think the game will be of like who's
the scroll will be more so and people
who are introduced as humans in in the
episodes or whatever or like oh is this
is this new computer interaction we're
having is
right now is that the actual
thing
I think it's going to be more of that
cat and mouse game or whatever new
humans are introduced yes or is this an
actual authentic character is this a
scroll I feel like yeah like there might
be
maybe one or two where it's like all
this time they've been a scroll or
something but I don't know I feel like
that would be hard to justify with any
of the characters who have had solo
movies yeah you know because then it
would make that it would create a weird
canonical gap for people I think if we
do too much of that
you know I think it's going to be way
more I don't think it's going to be as
the what's the one part that I think
people are kind of expecting when you
hear secret Invasion but I to my
understanding it's probably going to be
a lot more streamlined and really
focused on fleshing out the Scrolls as
characters where you're going to have
like one Camp because if I'm not
mistaken I've heard some of the
information from the Vanity Fair article
uh I didn't read the whole thing yet but
that yeah picking up from Captain Marvel
were Nick Fury promised them a home uh
that has not clearly happened for them
and that Amelia Clarke is the daughter
of Talos and apparently she was like
whoever the little girl scroll was in
Captain Marvel okay there's not a rumor
this is [__] with Samuel Jackson said
whoever the little girl was that's who's
grown up and then she has kind of a
resentment towards Nick Fury
exactly and and then some tension with
her father as well so it's kind of like
you do have some factions here go
occurring with them uh because I'm sure
Talos is not bad and I'm sure even the
bad scrolls are probably not going to be
portrayed as super villainous yeah but
they just have a different philosophy
and feel unfairly true they need a home
you know I'm sure we'll unders I'm sure
they'll do some acts that we don't agree
with but I I I'm under the impression
they're not going to fully portray them
as just like they are villains or maybe
they get to episode eight and then they
just do that yeah yeah yeah and then
they commit a mass murder yeah yeah
they'll be they'll be like the more
agreeable version of the flag Smashers
from uh the portrayal of the flag it's a
show right not a movie secret Invasion
yeah is the show yeah okay it is the
show and then Secret Wars is the most
yeah I know I don't see your words
I just been making sure
sure because there's sometimes I see
people say movie and I'm like wait a
minute what yeah
yeah
um yeah no it's a series
Carlos we answered this my friend
Jason Momo wasn't wrong about the Snyder
cut
Richard Nixon I have been working out
oh thanks for joining and you're not a
crook
and it's going to be a six episode
series no doubt well well we can't spoil
John Wick in here move past this fast
whoa no John Wick spoilers protect John
Wicked all cops I do think they should
end it
I know I saw that that I don't know if
it was an April Fool's headline but
that's just sort of like the sheer
amount of money is making them consider
a John Wick five and I'm like no no no
just leave it for right now just let it
be come back in 10 years we can't I
can't do it yeah already 70. yeah and
then try it but yeah for right now it's
such a beautiful piece just let it be
Let It Be gonna need a gun
I'm gonna need a cortisone injection
going to kill you
I filed my AARP
I need to go to the doctor
he's always confused in that movie
prostate is swollen
pretty sure I have internal bleeding
uh that's these bones are much mushrooms
I think the lines he does best in that
movie are when the lines are written
like questions yes and then he takes
declarative sentences and then turns
those into questions
gonna kill you
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah you're gonna start a war
just give me a gun
I really enjoyed this format it's very
chat inclusive oh good uh
yeah it took a while to figure out how
to best to incorporate the chat but we
love you guys we want you to feel seen
and heard
touched and felt and fondled
and then sue us and then yes show us
something tall or the real rejects
touched your soul
nfx visuals
have you guys checked out Barry hobo
thank you for the Super Chat I highly
recommend it stars Bill Hader and Henry
Winkler oh Greg loves him a berry
to me
is one of the best television shows of
all time and I do not say that lightly
Bill Hader
is I'm gonna look up has he should be
clay face is he he would be a great
Clayface um is he directing any movies
because there are episodes where I'm
like you are one of the best directors
I've ever seen like add that to the list
uh best directors working right because
I just don't know of any movies he's
directed I mean has he directed any
movies
for acting
oh yeah because
if you guys haven't seen Barry it is
this there's no real way to describe
Barry
it starts off like as an LA Noire
dark dramedy but then it just sometimes
turns into the coolest action [__]
you've ever seen there's this there's
this Chase sequence in season three done
with no music
on like that goes into the highways and
neighborhoods it and it's no music the
entire time
and it is so gripping and intense and
it's a bill hater directed episode oh
I'm excited and you could you you feel
like they let they you really let them
direct the episode you don't it's not
controlled here's the right
um and then uh yeah go to the director
he's only directed for Barry and there's
no upcoming that's what I mean I'm like
when's he gonna direct a film it's gonna
happen he is a phenomenal director and
he's directed like so much of Perry yeah
the pilot was written and directed by
him
um I think I think so
uh vitally impressive either way I mean
even if it wasn't I mean the fact that
once you get to like what season three
or four it's like he's directing it all
and it's a great character study and and
it's odd but it it never feels like the
show is in conflict or trying to come up
with something and it it there are some
of the funniest [__] I've ever seen on
television and some of the most intense
moments I've ever seen like it there's
nothing like Barry is great and I'm
keeping it for me I'm not gonna react to
it
all right it's not opening mines it
would be a good reaction John all right
if there's have you not seen it no I've
only seen one part of an episode
have you ever seen any of Barry not
really oh my God it's like the best
thing ever I mean I might have watched
the pilot way back and I and I saw a
piece of an episode where there's this
Barista who keeps giving people advice
it was very funny yeah it's fine season
three yeah yeah but but yeah I haven't
seen much at all of Barry
um Cruz Rivera that's that's one of
those shows where I'm like I want to
watch this on a consistent basis so I
can really take in and and yeah so I've
been like saving it for some I love that
it is a phenomenal and they're and
they're and they're short seasons and
the average episodes only a half hour
oh yeah cool like they they keep that
[__] tight
um but it's great uh yeah Cruise the
next season is the last season and I
think and I'm glad it is it should be
the last season
yeah it seems like it's staying just
right along as it means weird day and
age where we end things on a four
yeah cruiservera do you think Seth Rogen
thank you for Super Chat Metrology time
second one do you think Seth Rogen my
God what is wrong with this Mouse uh as
and Evan Goldberg could Helm a Marvel DC
property they're basically the John
Favre of Amazon Prime and TMNT yeah I do
I think it'd be a great addition to
anything I mean they could be a new
James Gunn when it comes to like
preacher and the boys like they and they
really know Comics sure especially Seth
Rogen they really know Comics I I feel
like they be
I don't think they should do Marvel I
feel like they'd be a fantastic addition
to the DC Universe though sure yeah the
the that's the the riper fit yeah if
they were gonna do a Marvel I feel like
they would have to do a special kind of
what if he kind of project yeah
something where they can direct it
themselves I mean it might be too
similar to boys I mean they're not the
same thing um but something like
Authority I'm like that might be a cool
Seth Rogen Evan Goldberg property yeah I
mean they can certainly do it
you give them Booster Gold
um would you like to see bad batch live
action at Mando no because I think it
spoils the fate and future of them for
me
sure
um
whoa that's interesting music
I had a chance Nora from Miami hey Nora
Nora
the writing of Avatar 4 is writing
Fantastic Four yeah oh yeah I saw that I
think the um
I think the addition of this writer is
great because he's worked more on like
serious sci-fi projects like epics yeah
not the writers who they who they had
before which did like funny stuff they
were more like animated comedy yeah this
is like snow piercer and [__] yeah
this is more this this will give it a
different type of sci-fi heft to it I I
believe yeah I think it's heartening
actually as much as people think it's a
good pick I think it's a really good
pick for Fantastic Four yeah it's a good
pick and I think as much as people have
been panicked hearing certain things
like this like oh they're rewriting
blade oh they're rewriting Fantastic
Four I'm actually happy about that
because it shows that they're paying
attention to one of the most important
parts of the process of these movies
that they haven't been nailing lately
which is the scripts yeah so good news
um and there are other writers I'm sure
some of their work will make it in there
yeah Andreas we have shopzeroedition.com
for our [__]
Jump On It
for our poops
uh did you hear about the Scott Pilgrim
versus the world they're making an anime
at Netflix with all of the original
movie cast anyway and I believe the
comic uh Creator is uh behind it as well
yeah we're gonna do it man we're gonna
watch it we're gonna react to it I'm
excited let's do it we'll have read all
the Scott Pilgrim novels and I don't
love that movie like everyone else I
feel like that's maybe the last
I liked last night in SoHo a lot I like
baby driver but I feel like Scott
Pilgrim
does that come before worlds then that
might be the last one I I loved you just
there's something about that movie that
like I love parts of it I do they're
they're elements that I really love Yeah
but overall I'm like yeah I like it but
I'm not I'm not everyone else when it
comes to that movie yeah that's for sure
but everyone I know like that movie
you've got a hardcore like people beat
that [__] up Daniel Salazar time is it
John okay
fairly soon
what's up from Miami well what's up from
your Super Chat what do you guys do you
guys think we'll play Doctor Doom in the
MCU I want them to cast them so we can
stop getting this question Daniel I'd
love to see Killian Murphy the writer
from Avatar 2 is gonna play doctor Dooms
I think Bill Hader should play
I would love that Doctor Doom
[Laughter]
two different voices he's one of the
best voice ever yeah I know I know I
know I'm just trying to imagine his bill
hater voice actual bill haters yeah
um who's like a different pick Bill
Skarsgard
uh Ron Pearl I think if they go old they
should go Clancy Brown
CB is he's he's he's in that position
now where you're like yeah you need a
heavy but who can do kind of the range
and play in the middle of morality get
Clancy Brown
I'm glad he's getting his flowers Mr
Krabs deserves it well I think you're
you're a little more used to Clancy
Brown in these like powerful almost
Regal like roles now yeah I've seen some
of his work from when he was like much
younger but like he was
essentially the main bad guy in Dexter
the reboot and he's like a very
he does great in that and they're like
for a lot of this the show he's just
like the the like a nice guy and uh okay
yeah he's great he's excellent in that
and it's very different than what I'm
used to seeing him cast as which is like
show up his stupid conditions totally
totally that's cool oh yeah I'm glad
there was at least something of value in
that last uh
do you think Beau and dim will share the
throne yeah you get this half let's just
get off my half yeah off my house just
squeezing in here man
yeah just squeeze your butt on the side
of there uh yeah I I hope sorry [__]
Ramirez just said I Jonathan Byers they
need to give Jonathan Byers some things
if they don't I think that will be a
general a genuine like
markdown for this series if they don't
pay off Jonathan in a satisfying way
thank you Annie Castro nice to see you
here love you and your comments Tony
Koto
good choice for Supergirl in the
Supergirl movie if they don't go with
the actors from The Flash
and yet on it's actually Anya Anya
Taylor Joy would be interesting
yes she would and I mean she she's
blonde so I could see it I don't
necessarily see her her as super girl
though I would cast her as other DC
characters first
but then again
I don't know would you cast her
yeah why not
why not
fine she's good she's in a lot of stuff
I wouldn't be like excited necessarily I
would want to be taken a little by
surprise I guess like
there's something with people's careers
when you do get to the point where you
feel like you see them like too much
yeah yeah totally and you do get to that
point and I think Ryan Gosling
if there's one thing you can credit that
guy for doing he really knows how to sep
like give you time away from him yeah
totally because there was one year
there's the year he blew up he had Drive
Ides of March right and Crazy Stupid
Love three very different movies three
very different performances
and then he started to catch on to there
might be getting too much uh people were
memeing me all yeah yeah I'm becoming
everyone's Bae I need to step back then
he took a wild break came back gray man
now there's another period yeah Barbie
like I I think he he's really smart
about that yeah where you don't feel
like you get too much Ryan Gosling sure
and I feel like people could take notes
from that yeah somehow he really he
really knew to do that yeah like early
like early on to like with the sensation
rise of him sure
um and I need to say other Joy's like
almost
or I'm like she hasn't given me a bad
performance but uh but it is like I see
you a lot now she is she is one of like
the short list of names that comes up
especially if it's like a blonde
character I mean at the point where
she's playing Princess Peach you're like
okay yeah I mean we're pretty much there
you know
uh I mean yeah she's gonna enjoyed all
of her performances thus far I think she
would be a good a good one I think she
would be great I'll be I'd be curious to
see her bulk up and we haven't really
got given her like those really big
action role yet
I saw most of it oh that's a John answer
I haven't seen any of it I was I watched
it on the plane and then the plane
landed when there was 15 minutes left oh
no you'll never know how it ends so I to
this day I'm like I don't know how that
movie ends how does Jonathan Byers oh
sorry I I meant to say will up above but
yeah how does Jonathan Byers and Arya
Stark and and you know the witch get out
of it
I don't know I don't remember the movie
um
um oh here we go
um hey guys what do you think we created
a greater disruption to the world order
Trump being re-elected president or koi
actually disliking something
is probably koi probably koi yeah if you
if you just like came out and like truly
panned something uh I think people would
be out in the streets looting koi is a
wildly unhealthy association with the
internet
he's got such a strong opinion about
internet and comments and feedback and
Twitter and he's always like so engaged
with it he's like well use this fuel
work out I'm like you're just justifying
your your excuses for this addiction is
the toxicity side yeah yeah you're just
addicted to the conflict is like you're
used to be so much happier because it's
like but no I mean I I think koi can
dislike sort of things that yeah but
he's more respectful too as well
um when it comes to disliking something
I think he does a good job in handling
disliking something yeah because
um he's never dog piling on something or
or like unless you put him in a spoiler
talk
sure yeah but but usually it doesn't
seem like he takes joy and yeah so it's
it's a more sober portrayal of the
negative opinion than just like oh man I
[__] hated this you know yeah yeah
and a good respect for all the work that
goes into these things as as somebody
who engages with so many people involved
with all these things I get the sense
that yeah he has a good amount of
respect for the undertaking
I missed the Arc Light I do too
yeah man missing it it's classic theater
I drove past the Cinerama Dome just
recently and and shed a tear
a single tier
a popcorn tear
Muhammad knew the Salome if we were
talking about that's right
Christian unpronounceable Mephisto
definitely he's here he's with all of us
he's in the details you know there's
something about
after all that one division stuff I'm
like you know what
I'm not even excited from Mephisto
anymore
and once it gets here it won't live up
to any of the weird Madness that that
you know brought us
what I wish hat didn't I wish they
didn't reveal that mephisto's coming
yeah
so far out because imagine you're
watching ironheart which is the show you
expect from Fisto to show up sure but
imagine you're watching ironheart
and then Mephisto suddenly appears
it'd be like what this is happening he's
here yeah yeah yeah
I mean they can't it's so hard for them
to keep anything secret now but also I
guess I appreciate when they try because
then you if you if you have people
leaking stuff like you understand that
that's just part of the thing but like
for them just to be like no he's coming
I mean they don't they managed to get
the Quicksilver with Evan Peters like a
week before it came out
like a week before the episode premiered
yeah they're this close yes
same thing with uh the the cameos and
Multiverse of Madness yeah
so like a couple days before yeah
it's a real bummer it was the day of the
premiere uh-huh that's when it came out
that when it went to the premiere sure
it's like oh god oh no yeah yeah the
cat's always gonna come out of the bag
but yeah it would be nice not to know I
mean I've heard that that rumor about
what the Mephisto project could be
and if there's any truth to that it
sounds like fun but also I would much
rather be shocked yeah yeah especially
after all the build up and fan out uh
hubbub
uh John Wick 4 and I'm see I'm glad
that's one of the reason we're talking
about the sound design watching it in
IMAX with the sound design and picture
oh yeah yeah I don't regret waiting I
don't regret skipping waiting to react
to it here I really I love that movie I
think it's a masterpiece yeah it is and
and and like one of the most like it's
Taylor Made for the IMAX experience like
the IMAX experience is so Exquisite they
didn't shoot it on IMAX cameras but I do
understand you get that right perfect
seed and you get to take in the picture
yeah because I think like Dolby would be
more comfortable especially for the the
run time uh to like sit open their feet
you know like that sounds way more
comfortable for for that than this IMAX
has this weird thing where they're like
how do we make our seats really
uncomfortable for everyone
[Applause]
and I'm like
every one of them looks like a space
station now I'm like how did you not get
the cushy chairs yeah there's something
about specifically
IMAX where they go we don't need to give
them comfortable seats do we I wonder if
it's like a cost concern of like you
know it's a specialized theater we only
have like one of them per year usually
only at like one of them per series of
screens so maybe to get enough people in
these are the chairs that make it so
that we can fit enough I don't know but
I do I but I still love IMAX I love like
if I'm gonna watch Oppenheimer on IMAX I
am so excited gonna watch ghost uh not
Ghost Protocol dead Nations
I'm gonna watch that on IMAX like there
are certain movies where no matter what
I'm watching IMAX however there's I'm
gonna be a little more selective now
that if I'm like well I do want to watch
some theaters but I'm going to Dolby
because
because sometimes the IMAX seats are are
not the most comfortable sure
um although I will say
the least comfortable way to experience
John Wick chapter 4 is in 4dx did you
watch it in 40x yeah I joined my friend
and it was the kind of thing where he
was like I'm going you want to come and
I'm like you know I gotta I gotta see it
again let's do this you know and and I
haven't seen you a while let's do this
and he was like yeah okay 40x and I
almost didn't go because I was like I
know already that this is going to be
too much for this experience and it's
gonna be like I'm gonna probably be
working against the the experience to
enjoy the movie and it was a bit like
that because I would hate that because
they do calibrate those chairs to really
go hard and so like it's just like
you're sitting there getting beat up for
three hours and like you know when cars
crash or anybody shoots anybody it's
just like
and like yeah you spend the whole time
just trying to like activate your core
so you can offset the motion and just
see the screen and I was like this was
still a terrific fit like the film is so
good that I still loved it and had a
great time but I was like
the this kind of movie I will probably
skip in 4dx yeah well sometimes 40x can
make you focus on your chair yeah
totally and what's happening in this
vicinity then the movie when it's
supposed to be a seamless immersive
experience yeah where it's enhancing it
but that is uh you're just getting
pummeled it's like it it elevated
quantumania and it and it was the right
experience for that it was the perfect
immersive fantasy but for something like
John Wick it's just like dark serious a
lot of violence yeah it's just like
you're just getting pummeled
jinx916 thank you so much for the Super
Chat
um what am I trying to say today John
would you guys be up for watching the
expanse or have you or have any of you
watched already it's been recommended me
several times I I've known almost
nothing about it but it's been
recommended to me a number of times that
I know a lot of people really love it
maybe so it might be I mean it's been a
couple of I I have a list of again
criteria is how interested are we in
actually just watching it so I never
covered Severance and then someone I
think it was Michael Tessler told me the
plot of severance and I was like yeah
what is it about damn I don't even know
what it's about and then uh
and will our audience be interested in
it and I have a solid third one but and
it's kind of I keep forgetting what that
one is but uh there is a three criteria
of it oh Oh you mean our interest the
audience interest and then just the the
exchange of value for time yeah what is
the will it attract new people too will
it be a reach will it grow will it reach
out yeah Beyond yeah yeah the couple
people asking for it I believe Val is in
secret Invasion yes I would I would
imagine so I don't know this mustache
girl Amazon commercial nor do I we
should get Goose back in secret Invasion
hope so
it's the best character Goose oh we got
two back-to-backs
our Rambo Rio Rambo thank you so much
for the Super Chat and thank you guys
who have left a like so far do you think
Monica would be in secret invasion I
mean I the sound stands the reason that
she would appear in secret Invasion yeah
maybe a scroll version though I think
we'll get [__] like that sure you know I
don't think they do something like
Chris Evans here what cap is just back
yeah no I I think we'll get a few Legacy
fake outs as Scrolls I think we'll get
yeah some I think it's it's more likely
yeah that you'd see like a Val or a
moniker or something in here yeah and I
would be very much open to that I'm very
excited and with the involvement of you
know coming out of Captain Marvel anyway
and then you've got the Marvels I feel
like even though secret invasion is not
like the connective tissue there's
certainly ample opportunities given that
you know uh Universe Connie sang Thank
you so much for being here Connie my
dear I miss you too miss you guys have a
great weekend Connie I am not seeing
anyone this weekend
there's so much to get done
right after this stream low kids and
tomorrow I there's no like is one of the
weekends we're like I'm not seeing
anyone I got gonna get a lot done
um so yeah but I I'm
sometimes people think like I'm
prioritizing hanging out with other
people
I'm like the truth is I haven't really
gone out before so Connie uh we have to
see you again soon but thank you thank
you everyone's contributed to the super
chats again and also thank you to
everyone who's left a like
is that you have you left a like yet
upcoming horror movies you're most
excited for oh easily my answer that I
think Josh is going to steal from me is
Evil Dead rise and saw 10. that's right
and uh can't wait for us to watch a
certain movie here on the Channel that I
will not name oh sure you'll keep you'll
see it yeah
um but John what about you
uh I want to see Ari Astor's new movie
oh Bo is afraid sure yeah
um
that's all the spookums that I've
worried about right now I'm like are
there any other there must be I'm sure
uh but yeah the shark the Tommy wise
though shark movie obviously yeah yeah
meg2 meg2 my favorite uh movie
and then Meg two uh the same weekends
they can duke it out they should give
Megan too like a crazy title like dawn
of the Megan's
Megan Rising uh uh uh yeah what's uh
what's the number number based pun you
can do that's the thing
Megan unplugged yeah but the G's are all
fives
I do love that movie I thought Megan was
a blast yeah Mega was really fun Megan
Megan is like the right kind of not
Blockbuster budget but you know one of
them it's one of those really Snappy pop
horror movies I have way more fun with
that than cocaine bear
uh in a different it's more madcap
certainly in a weird way it's like
throughout it's just kind of wild I
think I think the scenes in between the
violins are just like it's it's fun I
think it's more fun movie sure and it
has a little more build to it yeah it's
a little more unified and consistent
there I'm excited to see Patrick
Wilson's Insidious movie that he's
directing oh yeah that's right yeah and
they're I need to get a surgery
[Laughter]
I need to go to the further I need
to shoot a ghost I hope that oh my God I
want this movie I hope that there are
sequel to the nun can do that thing that
all of their spin-off movies do where
the first one is kind of crappy and then
the second one they get some kind of
upcomer to make a great version and then
there's the there I feel bad about that
because I really like the director when
we got to meet him he was so nice I know
of course they're nice well and he's
he's uh he's doing stuff like he's he's
he's out there you know hustling and
kicking ass so I'm happy for him because
I liked his Direction on that movie but
uh but yeah and then I guess the other
one I'm curious about is uh as much as I
am very mixed on David Gordon Green's
Halloweens he's doing an exorcist so
we'll see how that goes we'll see let's
say hey Mark Leach one of our patrons
and just a good friend shouts out to
Mark Leach and to core and Hardy hi
Coran Hardy watches this channel seven
maybe do Severance one of these days I
don't is it worth just not knowing what
this setup is probably because I just
keep hearing it's amazing does it do
well for other people sometimes that
helps to tell
Severance a great metric episode one
reaction
[Laughter]
the harmony
because there are some times where it's
like oh wow this person's breakdown did
amazing but reaction I don't know
yeah it doesn't look like it's doing
that great
this is like a huge show I thought it
was like an insanely huge show I mean it
it's
just the one this is just the one where
it like the people who watch it are very
such a passion for it I've heard a lot
of people reference it in multiple
sphere it's not just people like who are
you know spending time talking about
movies and TV all day that I've heard
this from so that gives me some kind of
hope that it is truly a standout um but
I don't know too like
uh does everybody have Apple TV plus I
feel like that's that's like a small
amount yeah like my yeah my folks have
it but like they they have it to watch
Ted lasso but I like I don't have it man
I hear there's a lot of like great stuff
there but I don't have it yeah and
they're and they just you know sort of
committed to doing theatrical movies too
now so I mean they're certainly On The
Rise I mean they their work gets a lot
of respect yeah I've heard even
shrinking is great people are going nuts
for shrinking right now I've heard and I
had an exact show idea about that I know
do you remember that idea I called it
Henry's patience yeah
[Music]
exactly yeah I thought it was a clever
title yeah because he's lost patience
with his patients yeah perfect I thought
it was I thought and that was my exact
show idea and then I saw the trailer I
was like oh
but this looks fun sure Harry Harrison
Ford's great in it real three R1 okay
thank you so much for being here my
friend running around in different live
streams to show my appreciation for the
hard work you guys do for our enjoyment
love you boss voice uh yeah I hope you
contributed more to ours than everyone
else's though yes that's what counts
most that's what counts most yes we we
directly rank you all based on that hey
guys are you watching succession if so
what are your thoughts on the episode of
the new season I don't even know what
succession is about I know what
succession is I've heard like White
Lotus is great I've heard successful
session is great yeah there's a lot of
shows that I'm just behind on we I mean
we've obviously been doing a lot more
movie reactions yeah because you know
like sometimes it can be bad when you're
like oh crap we're stuck with the Witch
season two and no one's watching this
video no one likes this anymore and we
just did all this ketchup on the first
season
yeah although at least the season two
hype helped out the season-wise yeah
but it's a nicer to catch up on movies
honestly I love I love ketchup the movie
reactions have been more of the actual
like you know it's less of a bump like
you think about it from RN too like we
did ICU
um which is not doing well at all abuse
um I love our video I do I genuinely
love our video really enjoyed the movie
nice surprise
um
but it's easier to be like oh this one
thing did not do well yes instead of oh
no we're here at like we have a 10-week
commitment yes yeah yeah I mean which
which has happened yeah and so like
beyond that too it's just nice to you
get more variety with the movies like
we're like they're doing like Disney
Dreamworks animated movies horror action
you know like we're doing there's more
variety and I like it
um yeah as far as you can hear about uh
attack on title man can't wait for that
Bucky Barnes thanks for holding down the
chat my friend Fanta so nasty
do you thank you for the Super Chat do
you guys think Blue Beetle would with
brown one of the big what what the hell
was this question is it supposed to be
will be one of the biggest and newest
gross oh film I thought there was like
some weird Mexican joke here I was
wondering that as well yes like oh God
do I participate in this hey do it am I
just racist for inserting that into my
own brain
this is your psychology is bare naked
I'm trying to prevent racism have I
inadvertently become racist yeah it's
over since sensitivity racism there you
go do you think Blue Beetle will be one
of the biggest and newest grossing films
from DC no
um yes I I'm holding out hope for Blue
Beetle because there's a lot of
interesting things you could do for Blue
Beetle uh I I think that you know first
off Latin character
right yeah Jaime
uh Jaime Reyes I think that is a great
and imagine the rest of the cast too
well or at least the game out of it oh
wait we got one we got the lead all
right don't get don't get cocky I'm not
super familiar with Blue Beetle I've I'm
more like yeah I've played the Injustice
games I've seen my other animated
mediums as well sort of com runs I've
read that he's appeared in but I've
never been the one to like I'm gonna
read just a dedicated Blue Beetle comic
but I think with his power sets and
stuff that would be fantastic to bring
to live action uh there's a lot of
really fun things I think they got the
perfect guy to be playing Jaime Reyes as
well and you can make it fun and I
magically capture that energy from that
first shazam movie
um and that's and so I think I feel like
it could it could actually and the fact
that they're doing Booster Gold who Blue
Beetle uh blue and gold the fact that
they're doing the Booster Gold movies
announced I I think helps give
reassurance that this is going to be
connected to the James Gunn DC Universe
and not just be like
yeah I like your one movie
start again this will not be the New
Mutants of the DC here yeah yeah I feel
like it'll actually be connected but um
I think it'll be a a reasonable hit I
don't think it'll be one of the biggest
though I think it'll be a good hit I
think yeah it'll do I think the first
Shazam is probably a solid metric I
think it will succeed hopefully on the
merits uh like them boosting it to
theatrical is a good sign that they have
a lot of faith in its quality so I feel
like the word of mouth will help because
I do
like Shazam has certainly comic book
clout and knowledge but I feel like for
a lot of people we are getting into a
point where we are going into the deeper
recesses of these catalogs of characters
so that your layperson might be like
Blue Beetle what is this sounds like a
hodgepodge character or Shazam what is a
Shazam you know so I feel like the
strength of the movie will dictate that
and yeah hopefully it will be a solid
success that can then be built upon
true thank you thank you for that why
does Ryan look adorable on the cape
because Ryan looks adorable without the
cape you should see him in just the cave
you should see me naked okay it is very
often
naked we'll do a naked live stream
people will be like Greg you look like
you've been gaining muscle you're like
yeah I know right with the right shirt
and everything Greg looks good he was
mad Greg takes the shirt off it's a long
time
not living up to my imagination right
now Greg sure sure of just like keep my
shirt
um Bucky Barnes my friend I appreciate
you guys as always leave a like reject
Nation you leave a like everyone I don't
know why that was like an insult back if
you leave uh if we get to to 5 000 likes
we'll do a naked the 10 000 naked live
stream uh okay you know what with
nothing but Jesus Real Steel is one I'm
constantly back I feel like I'm gonna
love that I love Sean Levy and I feel
like he's a very under recognized
director
um and and so I want to watch it I do I
feel like Real Steel will be pretty good
but I got it I gotta I got a certain
boxing movie I gotta get done this week
Oh yeah and when it's just a VOD release
that takes a lot more editing to make
sure that [__] ain't blocked I'm not
talking like one's well no I'm streaming
much easier to deal with copyright
issues and blocks but when it's just VOD
I'm like okay
let the games begin
I gotta make sure this doesn't get
blocked and I gotta make sure I got the
audience watching this for a good amount
of time yeah
um yeah don't worry don't worry uh let's
see nothing much happens
uh I don't watch wrestling I would like
to and I know so many people who love it
and I love their enthusiasm and uh yeah
I would love to take the time I want to
do a little experiment here because I've
noticed that we've had a little bit more
lady attention when it comes to
um
and for people asking John and Roxy have
done Ip Man too oh yeah it man who's
coming pairing up John with with the
women for the big reaction you're doing
Last of Us with Tara are you gonna do
put some boots and rocks to you sure uh
what are some of the should we
collaborating with Roxy
um yeah I'm like let's do the
experiments let's try Jennifer's Body
out roxycut that is that is a very fun
react I love that that's that's where we
go let's try trolls I love just we're
listening to you guys try to decipher
the Diablo Cody dialogue so okay even
cocaine bear has a 13 viewership of
female which is kind of unheard of for
us for at Elizabeth what are some other
horror movies that we've covered I'm
running an experiment here okay
um try barbarian barbarian smile okay I
want to see what like
because I feel like
weirdly enough like
okay that has an oh see Barbarian 19
female
okay normally our numbers are like 90
minutes
it's a barbarian surprise okay okay
let's try to smile
because I don't know any of this and I
and I I just I like to study analytics
to kind of gauge some things
smile 20 nice all right that's a great
that's crazy that's beautiful for us
yeah that's crazy here's one go back to
mid-summer mid-summer or mid-summer
however you say I still don't know what
I mean that's kind of old
um two years ago but it's it's Queen
flow like like let's let's check the
recent versus the old or or you could
try 23 23 that's great 23 you're next
that's a that's a female lead okay your
next was not did not perform well okay
your next did not perform well but let's
see what the audience is at
14. okay so it seems like seems like
when it comes to the horror movies
weirdly attract is normally it's like oh
if we do like a Disney or animated movie
like yeah we'll attract more of a female
audience um but
yeah 26 for the black phone really yeah
that's that's crazy yeah dude apparently
there's like a weird thing horror movies
because uh I'm always surprised when the
horror movies have like a good CPM like
how much does YouTube pay per like uh
yeah it's a weird conversion thing guys
how much does YouTube pay per woman
watch yeah but they've always said that
oh check Megan Megan recharge that's
good I like that as a title Sinister is
13 and a half but that's a male lead
I feel like there is maybe something to
be said for the female leads as well in
these movies black phone's not female
now that it's true though yeah it's
Ethan Hawkins okay Megan is
38.6 percent
that's pretty nuts because Norm I never
would have suspected that yeah and there
is a weird like we don't really set out
to be like we gotta get more of a feel
like we don't really set out to that
um but it is just so funny to see like
even Aisha is commenting on the ICU
reaction yeah
um it's just funny to see like oh who
would have thought that because because
YouTube actually this is weird thing
where they they give you a higher CPM
generally if it attracts more of a
female audience I don't know why that is
but they do I feel like YouTube in
general maybe just do it I I wonder what
the average demo of just all YouTube
viewers is and if it is more male
skewing and thus maybe those female
views are just and so it's kind and then
whenever I see comments in our live
streams
of of of uh horror a lot of the time
they're coming from
um the the female honey inside so I just
wanted to check really quick and I was
like oh damn there's something about the
horror movies that tap into that guess
what train to Busan is what yes just
take a guess 40 close 37.4 wow really
yeah that is wild to me
true that good to know I know that makes
one because we've been wanting to do
more like I love horror I think I write
is generally horror
um but anyway let's get back to Kingdom
reactions 25 really yeah I just yeah all
right let's get that uh we are on the
sixth season of my hero Academia and we
are loving the [__] out of that show yes
Deku versus classic it might be the best
season they've ever done yeah it's
really beautiful like the first half
takes place all in just this one chunk
of time and then the second half is like
some of the most intense and the the
challenges that are posing to the
ideologies I think is genius I love it
we're covering our patreon even though
patreon now is it being threatened for
anyone who's been doing uh anime
reactions I'm like great this was
supposed to be the safe space
and now now you guys are here to take it
all away yeah we got to kind of move a
little quick through this because we do
have to wrap up
um and uh yeah
uh okay Marseille Productions movie
reactions have been awesome thank you so
much appreciate the support via the
super chat too that means a lot buddy
Johnny Ronald McDonald versus Burger
King from the commercial let's do this
wait what is that actually a commercial
uh is it do they get the creepy ass
King who I love or is that Epic Rap
Battles I mean it's definitely but epic
rap battles should just get chat gbt now
to write the rap
God
it's so funny just take all the dialogue
From Any Given character feed it into
the machine and yeah write me a Rick
Grimes rap okay cool now write me play
me this guy's rap
uh we should see if chat GPT can write a
real rejects reaction video yeah see
what that would look like
I miss Epic Rap Battles man I love those
yeah why did they stop did they stop
making it they just make them once in a
while okay
it's just not I mean the [__] they make
is really hard to put together
I understand why they do a little like
five to six videos a year they're really
hard to put together yeah totally
um
I want my content ad nauseum
um real three r1k now I have oh thank
you you're the best man you're the best
Matt Brown
around
let's see here you've never seen IMAX
before you're doing yourself a
disservice go watch it online go watch I
think watch Oppenheimer on IMAX shoot
yourself properly with the right eye
mask so you get the hype like movies
that are shot with an IMAX camera yeah
um let's see here
damn I'm missing it John or are we
caught up for it are we caught up
uh let me confirm if we are caught up
yeah let's check it out because yeah we
should end the stream relatively soon
still got stuff to shoot today
I'm a female viewer the Hannibal TV
series is horror I've seen all the
Hannibal TV series I've seen none of the
Hannibal TV series it should is so good
it's real it's great people love it
oh you got the caught up oh my goodness
we're caught up yes thank you guys
appreciate you guys always leave that
like uh we do want to watch Battle
Royale oh yeah I would love to see that
all right oh I was thinking have you I
was thinking about pairing off you and
Roxy for this or are you and Tara
um have you have you seen old boy no no
do you know what happens in old boy
not really I've heard vague it's been a
while since I've heard any description
of old boy I've heard vague things about
it I just know that it's really messed
up but you don't know like you don't you
don't know pluck thing you know the plot
points or you don't know like the twists
or anything like that there's like a guy
in a box oh that's how the twist that's
what it's about all right that's about
all I know okay because
I'm a little hesitant because the the
content around it is like
messed up yeah it'll be a lot of
disclaimers for YouTube ahead of time to
be like this is all fictional yeah the
ad the ad suitability ratings will be
very very awesome um but I know for sure
that last half hour would generate
the best thumbnail face needless
like yeah I think that would be I think
that
um so either you and Terror or you and
uh Roxy I think for that one yeah I'd be
thrilled to let's get all two of them in
here
her and koi so that way they don't shut
up
and with the subtitled movie that's
gonna go even better yeah oh boy
um those guys yeah you just got to get
them a really talky movie the thing is
in that movie I I had to have a talk
with them
um about the thing
afterwards to give you guys an idea like
what I was saying earlier that if we
hire if we Outsource to it
yes hi how are you oh I hope you tagged
that photo
um I love meeting your son at the con as
well uh and what you said to me at the
con uh was insanely touching
um I will not repeat it because that's a
private moment uh but what you said was
one of it was one of the most
I don't I've never gotten a compliment
in person that has truly inspired me to
stay true to myself and to keep doing
what I do here so uh that was I've never
never been told anything like that in
person and I could tell it was coming
from a very real genuine place so uh
thank you for being there and uh I'm so
happy I got to meet your son uh both of
you but yeah I remember I definitely
I'll never forget that conversation I do
I was getting annoyed when people were
like we got to move you guys outside
because I was like what you're what this
person's telling me right now is this is
the real life what are the most like
craziest things I've ever been told
personally so yeah that uh yeah I'll
never forget that so thank you
I think if we're going to react to the
new evil dead I'm so excited that I mean
that's that's gonna be so hard to edit I
just know that movie's gonna be so hard
it's gonna be a very blurry reaction
yeah it's so hard to edit that
yeah I wish YouTube just didn't suppress
it when uh
when you get age restricted yeah I wish
they didn't suppress the video like the
disclaimer is there like let it do its
thing yeah come on yeah yeah
um ooh the call what is that no I love
Korean horror movies like Korea goes
hard yeah uh I I I I really and
sometimes when we're doing that [__]
like all of us are dead like I really
love that [__] man yeah shit's fun
oh all these I wonder if all these like
squid game all of us are dead if all
these you know Season twos are gonna
live up I mean I really want to see
Battle Royale yeah that's like a movie I
really want to watch hearing about that
movie
throughout my life yeah and so many
things compared to Battle Royale
um yeah I really want to watch that uh
but
uh what were we saying before
um we were talking about meeting at
WonderCon oh the thing the thing in koi
and right so normally if if like I'm not
in a the video
I if the prepper people aren't editing
the videos odds are on the one editing
the video now that being said if if uh
if I'm not in the video at all and it's
like a John if okay if it's John's doing
the video and I'm not in it like any any
like a movie or a show and he hands that
that usually prepper does the edit and
John handles uh the notes for the
re-edit on that one and for the thing I
paired up koi and Roxy and I've already
talked about them
uh Roxy took it like a champ she's like
she immediately understood it in the
choir like I really had to explain it to
him it was funny it was funny it's
something I just laugh about I just
laughing about it so normally and
they've both brought that back and
laughed to me about it yeah that's good
I'm glad they're both receptive if I
haven't if I'm not in it
and I'm doing a review I have to like
sync up the footage because I'm not like
I wasn't in the room when they're
shooting the reaction and it'll normally
take me like
roughly like an hour to to work on a
re-edit notes you know
um
for for if I'm not in it
and I had to tell both of them
because it wasn't a joke I was two hours
in to the to the at the re-edit of the
notes and I'm like I'm only at the 12
minutes Mark I remember you told me that
and sometimes it is like all right I
gotta talk to the editors about this but
then when I saw the raw footage and I
should have shot it too we were like
yeah you just sort of stopped talking
you mentioned it to me and then I was
like I gotta go look at this and then I
I saw it I was like oh yeah if I'm
sitting here going like whoa guys pay
attention to the film you know
something's wrong yeah yeah it was a it
was it was it was a very funny and it
took me over it took me over four hours
to just work on re-edit notes yeah for
that yeah to the point where sometimes I
was like look I'm just gonna edit this
part and just insert this in here yeah
like reclaim I remember that and then
yeah going back to the others you're
like here here's stuff for the first 20
minutes yeah that's right out I need you
to share the first 20 minutes I need to
see if this is Flowing now yeah here's a
bunch of in-depth reworking to do and
then if this works we'll do the whole
shebang yeah this is very very funny it
was it but no it's a very taxing when it
was done though I was like okay this
turned out good but I'm like no no I
should never be in a position ever again
yeah now I just laugh about it with them
it was it was it was like I can't
believe this has happened they've been
good sports yeah they've maintaining
they're bostonians they know how to take
it they know how to be like maybe don't
talk the whole time guys yeah sure sure
because I you gotta understand like when
we're doing these reaction something
people might know it's like one of us is
taking the lead in a video yeah and so
they kind of can follow the energy or
like one of us can make the call to be
like okay I'm gonna not engage in the
roofing back and forth as much right now
yeah
it's only yes
imagine starting a yes and right before
the credits start rolling like like you
have the best Instinct for that and over
time especially now being in in this
seat for more videos I'm like okay yeah
yeah don't don't just make this a riff
Fest because it's about being engaged
with the thing they were though in their
own way yeah to credit them they were
like they were engaged and like when
they were done shooting the reaction and
they came out to the living room they
were like we loved that that movie was
awesome yeah yeah yeah and so I thought
all right sweet this is cool perfect
gold mine let's go and then I was like
totally they were engaged in the way
that these two are okay
oh my God Louis Berry Hannibal is a goat
show mads deserved Eminem absolutely and
I wish they would resurrect it and thank
you for the Super Chat it's always
possible I don't even know what the on
my Block series is
um make sure to have two people for a
blind watch along yes
bring in the comment back
um half Trump half Batman make America
vigilante again I mean koi realized a
coin I realized on this live stream that
we did before uh that
I think Evil Dead rise should be a I
mean like as much as it would be fun to
do a reaction to a review I watched it
in the theaters yeah absolutely like it
looks like it could be a great theater
experience especially with a crowd yeah
yeah
um but at the same time I'm like you
know like you kind of show up to that
movie for like this this jump scares and
the gore and and like the wild craziness
yeah yeah so the mean Spirits yeah I'm
sure be I'm sure it'd be better in the
theaters than at home but I'm like I
think it would also be a great reaction
where honestly with John Wick I'm sure
would have been a great reaction yeah I
feel like two and three would be great
we only throw one into them like one but
John Wick 4 has these scenes of just
dialogue and no action uh at that I'm so
immersed in that I'm like I would
because you have to understand we we can
only show up to eight seconds of footage
of time yeah eight consecutive seconds
at a time you can't get all the mood sir
so we need to sometimes would be
conscientious enough to like Express a
thought out loud
you know Express something out loud
throw something to cut to express
something we sometimes we've got to be a
little conscientious of that and like
express it you know and uh sometimes
it's hard when movies like The Whale or
Schindler's List or I'm not exactly
going to be like making a bunch of
commentary yes um jokes especially but
John Wick I love just being quiet and
absorbing those moments uh and and I I
would have like yeah my preferential
viewing well I haven't seen it twice I'm
like yeah I'm glad we saw I'm glad I saw
us in the theaters uh but Evil Dead I'm
like nah man it looks like it'd be a
blast I share with the audience like
that would be the one to share with the
audience is even the action in John Wick
most of it I'm so engrossed in the in
the story that I'm not even like super
reactive yeah totally because I'm just
like so engaged yeah yeah and Evil Dead
is like as much as I love Evil Dead
movies and the theatrical experience
that easily is like nah that would be
like such a fun reaction even still I
feel like I would still have just as
much joy in the experience uh prerninsky
uh with sort of a coin I discovered in
our last live stream was that um
Batman
is a liberal is a Democrat a liberal and
then the persuade is a Republican
sure sure yeah because to have the
financial Empire that Bruce Wayne does
and also to keep the facade yeah yeah he
would have to be a conservative member
of his City at least somewhat maybe a
moderate conservative but yes yeah yeah
yeah direct I wanna that is though that
is the like if you think about it he is
like oh like like a a total liberal sure
as Batman yeah but uh like like I'm
talking like hippie liberal to an extent
yeah I'm a Marxist Stephen yeah like I
hate the system yeah taking back the
means of production he's going against
the man yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna make my
own operation and I'm gonna protect
people Wayne Enterprises
billionaire corporate yes how what are
the layoffs like at Wayne richest mofo
in the most corrupt city yes yes that's
how that's why you're crazy like I've
never even thought about that until that
time we did this dream I want a comic
book that explores that that's what uh
that's what would be uh uh yeah that's
why he created the baddest so he could
express those views also Aisha said uh I
saw the Devils one of her favorite
Korean horror films I've heard so much I
want to see that too yeah yeah yeah and
uh to whoever asked I have seen
everything everywhere I saw it opening
night you were the first person who told
me about the movie yeah and never even
knew what it was
I didn't even see the trailer for the
movie before I watched it I didn't
either I just heard that the Swiss army
man guys were doing it and it was
Michelle yo and the word Multiverse and
I was just like I'm there whatever it is
I'm there I mean people talk about
crying Greg and I'm like guys to this
day no movie has broke me like that
movie I was just crying throughout and
every time I've seen it it's just
there's a point where it just starts and
it just does yeah throw the Daniels in
there they're my favorite some of my
favorite directors working right now 100
I can if I need to like con like fight
back or hold back tears I can usually
do enough I was whimpering
straight up just whimpering whimpering
throughout yeah I was to the point where
I was working on notes for because I
didn't edit it I I was only worked on
the re-edit when I was working on the
re-edit I was a little embarrassed when
I was like
I just hear me [__] write it to the
mic that's that's a very intimate like
way to look in on yourself yeah yeah
um that was a great reaction too though
and uh and uh and it suppressed my
YouTube because it's got an age
restriction after all those extra blurs
and stuff that we would have later to
put uh made Smith uh uh uh Dalton Dante
uh you know there's Kingdom reactions on
the channel go check them out go check
it out if you love Kingdom watch it I
don't know what the best comment ever
made is it my favorite one is Anchorman
just yeah I do love Anchorman I think
it's genius man it's hilarious all right
we got to wrap this up we're gonna do it
right now uh Lewisberry thank you so
much for helping us end our super chats
experience here you deserved an Emmy as
well hope for season four you Dancy I
haven't seen it no no it's Hannibal oh
oh yes yeah dude Nancy's uh the guy oh
he's doing Friday and then uh yeah
it will uh he plays that but the guy who
did hannibals in Friday 13th I'm very
excited about that oh yeah the Crystal
Lake Show Bucky Barnes but we'll have uh
we'll have Jason Bucky Barnes thank you
for holding it down for a while have fun
at WrestleMania taking your son there
that's awesome yeah enjoy uh haven't
seen Tulsa King no I haven't seen any of
those shows uh I wanna I mean
Yellowstone I'm sure people have asked
us to react to but I want to watch that
uh with with the misses uh Louis Berry
season two of Hannibal's season 2 finale
at Hamilton two is one greatest of all
time episode yeah I I wasn't a huge fan
of season three
it got a little too
got a little too artsy fartsy for me and
and everyone started talking like not
people to me it it I'm not I'm not the
biggest fan of season three
um I like the show's super artistic but
once you once everyone starts sounding
the same and and talking the same and it
just becomes about communicating themes
and they stop sounding like real people
now I'm like they're never now you've
become pretentious you were like
perfectly RT for me and for the art
seemed perfectly violent and thrilling
but now you're just kind of bogged down
with some other [__] so if a season four
ever happens it'll be all Gore then
hopefully let's go in the other
direction uh just on April Fool's
article thank you Pub and Meyer for
contributing here buddy saying Harry
Styles cast of Superman Superman Legacy
to be honest I don't hate the choice
thoughts uh Harry Styles no I mean he's
already gonna be that other guy uh Star
Fox pervert uh already he's already
gonna be that guy uh I don't I feel like
Harry Styles also would be distracting
and I think Harry Styles
um I think he's a charismatic actor and
while I really enjoyed him in Dunkirk
and then you know there's a good amount
in
and don't worry darling but it yeah it's
the movie don't worry darling but I do
think Harry Styles I'm not saying he's
incapable I love watching actors grow I
I love watching actors get better
and I I can totally see Harry Styles
becoming like an amazing actor there's
not a slide against him but there are
moments in in don't worry darling where
it's like
yeah he's trying to do like a cry scene
and I could tell your Force it's not
working you know that was a movie where
I'm like I I think you should have
taken some smaller roles work up your
craft and then do it yeah there it is
yeah yeah but there were it's not like
he's bad throughout or something like
that but I do I do think he's got a
little like I think he'd probably be
great in comedies Harry Styles I feel
like he'd probably kill it the way how
Channing Tatum was not the greatest
dramatic actor and then he started doing
comedies and you're like oh [__] this
guy's like [__] amazing yeah she's
charismatic and fun and then that helped
his dramatic acting exactly yeah yeah
there is there can be a thing where it
like kind of recycles back into your
dramatic work and I think here like Fort
James Franco became you know what he is
now I think when James Franco started
doing comedies like Pineapple Express
Pineapple Express was the first time I
saw him in something that I was like wow
I'm really lost in the Rollies dude
uh yeah don't worry darling
44.6 female viewership really yeah
what's this let me see wouldn't it come
out uh this was November 7th 2020.
what was the uh see let me see the CPM
side of it
yeah it's pretty good yeah
thank you ladies for watching our videos
ladies of the reject Nation love
everything with red dragon in Hannibal
Louis Berry yeah yeah third season
um becomes like the the red dragon
adaptation oh good the best of the
movies
better than Hannibal I think okay is it
I don't know
better than Hannibal Rising okay but
Pattinson though I'm talking not I like
I don't Pattinson proved he is a
fantastic dramatic actor though before
the Batman came out yeah and anybody who
had seen those movies like no he can and
I'm going off of Harry Styles latest
film
police officer he needs a while ago yeah
yeah and I think too just his profile is
such that it would eclipse the character
I think it would Clash with the
character he's not an he's not in every
man in the same way I do wish that we
had like some event TV Go I mean we have
Mandalorian right now but there is
something about like Wednesday was like
oh this is [__] there's something
special here the water cooler show that
the globe is talking like a new thing
yeah like mandalorians returning a fresh
surprise yeah yeah but when you got
something that just comes out and takes
it by storm I'm like oh [__] you know
yeah no there's like that fun sort of
like thank you for being here Jennifer
all right guys we have to head out out
ourselves really do appreciate everyone
who's here please if you haven't done so
please leave a like
um and uh no I mean the live streams
they honestly like there is a weird
thing about the live streams where it
makes it more fun again to do the it's
always it feels like a great refresher
to even go back and do the regular
videos you know like getting involved in
the conversation so I I really I really
do love doing these live streams a lot
uh for for perk for just like there's
there's a personal selfish benefit that
I I I get in an emotional way uh and
mental Clarity way because so I
appreciate you all being here and uh
thank you all who contributed to our
super chats and I think you all
contributed to the stream Labs as well
thank you guys so much uh but keep a
lookout there's a lot coming out this
week
um secret Invasion Blue Beetle
spider-verse spiders I'm hearing about
this hypocrisy trailer
um a Creed 3 I'm going to be doing with
Andrew you saw it in theaters right yeah
yeah
um don't tell me about the IMAX but I
don't want to it actually was
bad it just didn't it was one of the
movies still good it just I I wasn't
like ah this is clearly being elevated
by IMAX oh that's good to hear I was
like I could have seen this in a normal
theater and felt just fine all right
that helps yeah yeah and I'd heard so
much about people being like no in IMAX
and I was like yeah I mean there's some
good shots they're like it looks good
but but yeah it didn't to me beg the
IMAX account okay yeah
yeah I think now too to cover a Jonathan
Majors movie is the perfect the right
time SEO
yeah
but every one of our little news videos
at the end and also uh Sally The Monaco
was visiting town and
um we shot Pitch Perfect
I'm telling you guys right now I love
the [__] out of Pitch Perfect oh fun I I
was so happy like oh yeah I I thought it
was amazing yeah I I genuinely love the
hell out of it and I did not know it was
even about acapella oh cool that's how
little I knew about I mean I covered
this stream Lab didn't I didn't cover
the latest streamline yeah yeah it was
only there's like one yeah I got the one
unless you just snuck it in right there
oh there you go up right oh thank you so
much no Chanel just said just wanted to
try it out thank you so much successful
trial thank you
uh thank you for making sure the Bell
works yeah I appreciate you very much no
Pitch Perfect was a blind reaction thank
you Jordan Garza thank you so much hey
don't worry you're here and at all and
uh John and Roxy shot two shot it man
too so we got a couple things that are
edited uh I just gotta make thumbnails
and prep the metadata and all that stuff
which takes a while but then um and then
we got Mandalorian so it's gonna be a
busy week and also I got family visiting
so I gotta also I gotta sit down find
some time for um
family visiting I want to make sure I
spend plenty of time with them
um but thank you all for being here once
again uh we love you now thank you so
much oh yeah no Chanel and Jordan Garza
two different people what the hell
because I thought why why why did I
forget about the stream oh he said why I
forget about the stream today guys those
fortuitous I thought you said I thought
did we both read it the same I think
maybe we both read it as stream Labs
yeah yeah no why did I forget about the
stream today and then Chanel's
contributed to the streamlabs saying
just wanted to try it out it's hilarious
oh thank you thank you sir thank you so
much notion thank you both thank you and
hey Jordan you you made it in at all as
long as you leave a like you are perfect
yes yes alrighty guys thanks again this
is another fun stream uh we want to do
them uh regularly and then hopefully we
got a koi around for the next one
uh yeah alrighty guys well I'll chat
with you all soon much love peace and
love guys thank you
ending the Stream